Für den vorletzten Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz, denn der Blue Moon ist normalerweise, also traditionell der vorletzte Mittwoch im Monat, ist angesiedelt das Chaos Radio und das findet heute ein bisschen früher statt. Diese Woche eine Woche früher als sonst, denn es gibt einen Termin nächste Woche und deswegen müssen wir uns diese Woche schon mal ranwagen mit dem Chaos Computer Club zusammen. Auf der anderen Seite, also links und rechts von mir gegenüber stehen Andreas und Frank.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Max Tromalowski, wunderschönen guten Abend. Thema heute Abend wirkt auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen kompliziert, betrifft dann aber irgendwie doch jedermann und jedermann sollte sich so ein bisschen damit beschäftigen, weil das wahrscheinlich in den nächsten fünf oder zehn Jahren zwanzig Leute dann auch in der Umsetzung auf uns zukommt. Stichwort ist in diesem Fall E-Government und da gebe ich auch schon Aktion, was das eigentlich bedeutet, erklärt ihr zwei jetzt nämlich.
Ja der Bericht ist eigentlich ziemlich weitläufig und wir wollen versuchen uns jetzt in der Sendung das ein bisschen den Begriff zu umrunden und einzukreisen, was damit eigentlich gemeint ist und vor allem auch welche Möglichkeiten das für die Bürger bietet, sich zu informieren, was der Staat eigentlich macht, das heißt, da so ein bisschen reinzuschauen in die Verwaltungsvorgänge, andererseits welche Gefahren wirkt es, wenn ich jetzt über all den Datenbanken gespeichert bin, meine Amtsgeschäfte elektronisch machen kann, was passiert damit dann mit meinen Daten und wo muss ich darauf aufpassen?
Also im Grunde ein bisschen auf einen Punkt gebracht würde, das ja heißen E-Government, vielleicht kennen ihr einige schon sowas wie Online Banking und haben das schon mal gemacht, sie machen jetzt ihren ganzen Bankkram auf elektronischen Wege, dass sozusagen alles, wo ich irgendwo mit dem Staat in Kontakt treten könnte auf elektronischen Wege im Endeffekt mal passieren soll, wenn man es denn zu 100 Prozent umsetzt, wenn ich es so richtig verstanden habe.
Das ist die eine Seite der Medaille, das heißt also, das E-Government, das heißt elektronische Verwaltung, automatisierte Verwaltung, das ist die eine Sache. Die andere Sache ist aber der Anspruch des Bürgers, möglichst viel über die Verwaltung zu erfahren, was die gerade machen. Das heißt, ideal ist es so, dass jedes Gesetz, was verabschiedet wurde, oder auch jeder Entwurf, jedes Protokoll, Diskussionsprotokoll vom Bundestag, was auch immer, ist sofort online abrufbar. Das heißt, ich kann gucken, was sie da gemacht haben, wer was sagt und wie da die Interessen geschlagen sind.
Das wäre eigentlich ganz schön. Es gibt natürlich auch dann noch mal die andere Seite der Medaille, was Zementinfektions bedeuten könnte, was heute Abend auch zur Diskussion ein bisschen führen soll, die wir führen möchten im Chaosradio. Die 81. Ausgabe übrigens, an der ihr euch auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen, wie immer, beteiligen könnt, können wir auch am Anfang Gesendungen direkt mal sagen. Natürlich, da ist eine Talksendung, ist ja auf Fritz, könnt ihr anrufen unter 031 70 97 110. Wie wir ins Thema einsteigen wollen, verraten wir euch gleich. Wenn ihr aber eher so mailorientiert seid und vielleicht etwas ausführlicher im Laufe des Abends was fragen wollt oder was beitragen möchtet, könnt ihr das tun unter 81 at chaosradio. ccc.de. Das ist die Mailadresse, ich sag's nochmal, 81, geschrieben als Zahl, also 81 at chaosradio. ccc.de, weil wir irgendwie dazu neigen, diese Mailadresse immer erst in der letzten halben Stunde des Blumen munt des Chaosradios bekannt zu geben.
Genau. Allerdings müssen wir euch ein bisschen enttäuschen, weil wir haben ja im Studio nicht die Möglichkeit, Mails zu lesen. Das würde jetzt auch ein bisschen ausufern, wenn wir jetzt während der Sendung noch Mails lesen würden, aber das sind alles Sachen, die wir nachhinein auch beantworten. Da könnt ihr dann auch irgendwie noch Fragen stellen, Sachen noch einwerfen, wenn ihr was habt. Und wir haben außerdem was Neues, das möchten wir probieren. Es gibt im Berliner Chaos Computer Club eine Veranstaltung, die nennt sich Datengarten. Die findet ungefähr einmal im Monat statt. Wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir diesen Datengarten dazu nutzen wollen, die Radiesendung quasi vor Ort nachzubereiten, so wie es nicht. Ob das klappt, vielleicht kommen da irgendwie morgen 500 Leute, vielleicht kommen auch nur drei, das wissen wir nicht. Das findet statt in der Marienstraße 11 im Hinterhaus. Das ist also in den Räumen von Berliner CCC und das geht um 20 Uhr los. Da könnt ihr auch nochmal klicken bei uns auf den Webseiten, da gibt es noch Infos dazu und da wollen wir im Prinzip die ganzen Diskussionen, die wir hier führen, noch vor Ort weiter diskutieren mit euch.
Soweit also, bevor es überhaupt losgegangen ist heute im Chaosradio auf Ritz, schon mal der avisierte Nachklapp. Aber wir wollen natürlich auch mit euch talken. Darum geht es heute Abend. Wir haben drei Stunden Zeit uns über dieses Thema E-Government, also was mit der Regierung alles sichtbar jetzt in elektronischem Maße passieren könnte. Unterhalten, wie auch wie ihr eure Sachen in elektronischen Zukunft möglicherweise erledigen könnt. Einstiegsweise wollen wir einfach mal fragen, welche elektronischen Bürger-Services, sagen wir ruhig mal, würdet ihr euch wünschen? Also was würdet ihr gerne online oder auf elektronischen Wege erledigen können? Wenn ihr euch jetzt wirklich einfach mal frei von der Leber wegsagt, das hätte ich gerne. Beziehungsweise welche würdet ihr überhaupt nicht haben wollen? 031 70 97 110. Frage für das Chaosradio heute Abend. Hier hört das Chaos Radio auf, Fritz, der Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Ungewöhnterweise diesen Monat mal am zweiten Mittwoch des Monats, nicht am dritten Mittwoch, nee am letzten Mittwoch, Entschuldigung, am dritten, oh mein, jetzt bin ich hier durcheinander gekommen. Jedenfalls das Chaos Radio einfach mal in einem anderen Termin. Nicht, dass ihr euch wundert, dass es an nächster Woche nie stattfindet. Wir haben es vorgezogen und heute Abend geht es zusammen mit Andreas, Frank und mir, Max, um das Thema E-Government. Hört sich ein bisschen unschön und jetzt nicht so spektakulär an, als Begriff. Könnte es aber mal werden, weil es bedeutet, dass ihr entweder zum Beispiel alles, was ihr jetzt so machen müsst, beantragt euren Pass oder so oder ihr müsst irgendwo hin, um euren Wohnberechtigungsschein zu beantragen und diesen ganzen Driss, den man so in seinem jungen und alten Leben erledigen muss, das möglicherweise alles von zu Hause machen, von einem Rechner oder von wo auch immer, vielleicht auch von der Arbeit oder von der Schule aus und dass ihr auch das, was die Politiker da tun, die euch schließlich repräsentieren, online, auf direktem, sehr schnellem Wege verfolgen könnt. Darum geht es heute Abend im Chaosradio, das zu ergründen. Und es gibt natürlich die Frage, welche elektronischen Bürger-Services, was würdet ihr euch wünschen, was ihr allein zum Beispiel alles erledigen könnt und was würdet ihr euch nicht wünschen? 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer vom Chaosradio. Und am Telefon ist der Bernd aus Hangelsberg.
Was würdest du dir wünschen als Bürger-Service?
Ja, ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen, die ganze Schule von zu Hause aus am Computer zu machen.
Einschließlich den Klassenarbeiten?
Die kann man auch so, weil gut, kann man noch ein bisschen feiern, aber das wäre eine schöne Vorstellung.
Das glaube ich. Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Das ist eine tolle Idee, die Klassenarbeiten von zu Hause auszuschreiben.
Nee, ich meine, es kann so jetzt nicht morgens am Computer zu setzen, und dann hat man so eine Art Webcam für den Lehrer und dann kann man das alles über den Computer so bequatschen.
Das wäre jetzt schon eine ganz spezielle Form von E-Government, das ist der Teil des deutschen Staates, der dich erzieht, auch über das Netz zugänglich ist. Du würdest dir dann auch wünschen, dass dein Lehrer da in so einem kleinen Fenster ist, das kannst du größer und kleiner machen und so.
Genau, und der sagt dann, ja, tun wir jetzt deinem commercial Buch da öffnen und dann kann man zum Beispiel einscannen und jetzt von deinem Computer aus irgendwie berichtigen.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass da einiges verloren geht?
Gut, die schönen großen Pausen, die ich mir immer sehr gut gefallen habe, zum Beispiel.
Die anderen Leute?
Ja, richtig, aber ich meine, dann kann man ja auch noch so ein Klinkenstall haben.
Aber da kommt zum Beispiel schon mal die Frage auf, finde ich, was bedeutet das andersrum? Die würden ja wollen, dass sie auch kontrollieren können, ob du da sitzt. Und was würdest du dann zulassen? Würdest du zulassen, dass sie dir noch so eine Webcam auf dich richten und du darfst dann dich nicht von diesem Platz erheben für die nächsten 45 Minuten und dann darfst du mal Pinkelpause machen in deiner eigenen Wohnung?
Und nicht kippeln?
Ja, so könnte ich mir das vorstellen.
Immerhin.
Okay.
Und wie ist es mit Zeugnissen? Willst du das dann auch elektronisch haben?
Wie würde ich denn so über ihn kommen?
Kannst du dann einfach so ausdrucken, oder?
Das wäre jetzt schon ein sehr spezieller Fall. Ich meine, du wirst natürlich auch deine Kumpels gar nicht mehr wirklich treffen, ne? Also... Ja, Arbeiten von zu Hause schreiben und alles andere in der Schule auch von zu Hause machen. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Jo, also wenn ihr ähnliche Vorstellungen habt, vielleicht, es war ja jetzt schon sehr kreativ, was Bernd uns da geliefert hat, dann ruft an, 0331 77 97 110 zum Thema E-Government, heute im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, sich das so aus dem Kalten auszudecken. Gab es von der, zum Beispiel vonseite der Bundesregierung überhaupt schon mal so ansatzweise Bestrebungen, den Bürger mit nahe zu bringen, oder ist das so noch ganz kaltes Gelände?
Ja, es wurde jetzt, bitte, es wurde jetzt gerade ein Bündnis für vor allem auch elektronische Singaturen. Kommen wir später noch zu, was es ist. Aber diese ganze E-Government-Geschichte soll jetzt auch wirklich angegangen werden. Meins Ernst, weil sie merken nämlich auch, dass diese ganze Verwaltung sehr träge ist und viel zu viel Papier braucht und der Bürger auch mehr Einfluss... Genau, es kostet einfach Geld. Und Bürger sollen einfach auch mehr, das ist zumindest die Hoffnung der Regierung, sollen sich einfach auch mehr einbringen dadurch, indem sie da Möglichkeiten haben, Sachen einzusehen und Sachen auch online zu machen, dass einfach dieses schlechte Verhältnis, was jetzt zu den Behörden besteht. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ummelden muss, dann muss ich aus einer Meldestelle gehen, eine Nummer ziehen, drei Stunden warten und das ist alles ganz elend. Und damit ist natürlich auch so ein Vorbehalte gegen Behörden und es ist vielleicht auch die Hoffnung, dass das abgebaut wird. Aber wir haben vorhin auch gerade was in den Nachrichten gehört, was irgendwie auch ziemlich spannend ist, was auch brennend zu dem Thema der Sendung passt.
Und zwar gab es da eine dpa-Meldung, und wie gesagt, das Ansehen der Politik hat in Deutschland einen dramatischen Tiefstand erreicht. Nur noch drei Prozent der Bundesbürger haben noch Vertrauen in die Arbeit der politischen Parteien. Auch Arbeitsämter und Rentenversicherungen erhielten schlechte Noten. Das ist ein sehr beeindruckendes Zeichen. Zum einen mag das ja daran liegen, dass es nicht transparent ist, was sie da tun. Ich als gemeiner Bürger habe einfach keine Ahnung. Ich sehe die Bundesanstalt für Arbeit ab und zu im Fernsehen und das war's. Und das, denke ich, ließe sich besser machen, wenn man deren Arbeit transparent macht, dann kann man für jeden zum Anklicken, was tun die eigentlich, mit welchem Personalstamm, was für Geld verschwenden sie dafür, kann man das nicht effizienter machen. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es auch sehr schwierig geworden, sich zu beteiligen. Das bedeutet ja in der Regel nach Berlin fahren und Lobbyarbeit leisten.
Zum Beispiel.
Was würde das in dem Fall heißen? Lobbyarbeit leisten? Ich denke mal, dass die meisten Leute sich da drunter überhaupt nichts vorstellen können, was jetzt Lobbyarbeit sein sollte, wenn nicht zum ersten Mal.
Na ja, mit Politikern reden, direkt vor Ort sein, da wo Regierung gemacht wird. Das heißt also, wenn ich mich irgendwie einbringen will, dann muss ich das immer noch persönlich machen. Das heißt, ich muss da wirklich erscheinen. Oder mich dann mit den Leuten auch treffen. Und das ist sehr schwierig. Quasi auch elektronisch oder über irgendwelche Meinungsfindungsprozesse, Willensbildungsprozesse, elektronisch im Netz etwas voranzubringen.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst. Also ich meine, das ist schon ein bisschen her, aber wir haben glaube ich auf Fritz mal so einen Test gemacht. Inwiefern bekannte Politiker, also so Caliber Schröder, Westerwelle Fischer und so, nur mal auf ihre Mail reagieren, wenn man ihnen mal eine Mail schreibt. Im Grunde ist das ja der erste Schritt zur elektronischen Kontaktaufnahme. Und ein paar von denen haben überhaupt nicht zurückgeschrieben. Und ein paar von denen haben einfach nur aus irgendwelchen Pressemeldungen Sachen rauskopiert, da reingepastet und das war's dann. Also ich meine, die Arbeit wird ja immer noch dahinter stecken, auch wenn du das Medium auf einmal zur Verfügung hast, muss ja irgendjemand das Feedback trotzdem liefern.
Gut, es liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass es keine Antworten auf die Fragen im Netz gab, die da gestellt worden sind. Je mehr Sachen im Netz sind, je mehr über die Regierung öffentlich wird. Was sie machen, was sie tun, desto weniger Fragenbedarf besteht auch, denke ich.
Wir sind im Grunde in ungemachten Betten, könnte man sagen. Wir haben jetzt alle Möglichkeiten, es uns schön zu machen und einfach mal davon zu träumen, was da möglicherweise passieren könnte auf diesem Gebiet. Berlin und Brandenburg, wenn ihr irgendwelche Ideen habt, wenn ihr jetzt zu Hause sitzt und ihr seid so ein bisschen Rechnerfirmen und ihr macht schon so ein paar Sachen über euren Rechner und seid zum Beispiel bei Ebay unterwegs und habt da schon mal was ersteigert oder ihr surft regelmäßig irgendwo vorbei und holt euch eure News da.
Zum Beispiel ein Leichtflugzeug und ein Herzschrittmacher für 1, 5 Millionen Euro. Das war ich gar nicht. Zum Thema Verbindlichkeit im Netz und Signaturen kommen wir auch später noch zu.
Der klassische Herzschrittmacher für 1, 5 Millionen Euro, wenn ihr den auch mal ersteigert habt. Also wenn ihr einfach mal ein bisschen das Gefühl schon gekriegt habt dafür, was man möglicherweise alles übers Netz abwickeln könnte, dann geht mal in euch und fragt euch, was ihr von eurer Regierung eigentlich haben wollen würdet. Weil so eine Umfrage wie die, die wir vorhin zitiert haben, nämlich, dass die Parteien nicht mehr so viel Vertrauen genießen in der Bevölkerung, das ist ja relativ repräsentativ. Und ich nehme mal an, dass ihr zum Teil auch dazu gehört. Was würdet ihr euch wünschen, was ihr zum Beispiel von eurer Partei so online erfahren könnt? Ihr schickt da irgendwas hin und sagt, das und das würde ich gerne wissen können. Oder das und das würde ich gerne abrufen können. Zum Beispiel den Sachen Geld. Welche elektronischen Bürger-Services würdet ihr euch wünschen? 0331 70 97 110. Die Nummer vom Chaosradio heute Abend. Und schreckt davor jetzt nicht zurück. Ist jetzt nicht so, als würde Schröder hier zuhören und dann sagen, oh, bei Robert gehe ich auch mal vorbei, dafür dass er das gesagt hat. Ihr habt freie Bahnen, ihr könnt euch wünschen, was ihr wollt. Meldet euch 031 77 97 110. Danke für's Zuhören. Ich höre das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir haben es kurz vor halb elf, was bedeutet, wir haben noch gute zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit mit euch zu talken in Berlin und Brandenburg. Thema heute Abend, gläserne Regierung, gläserner Bürger, E-Government, ist das, was irgendwie alle sich so ein bisschen wünschen, aber keiner weiß genau wie er rangehen soll. Und solange das noch nicht entschieden ist, haben wir die Möglichkeit mit euch darüber zu talken, was ihr euch vielleicht wünschen würdet. Denn was die Regierung sich tatsächlich wünscht, ich hätte es ja selber nicht geglaubt, ist mehr Beteiligung vom Bürger und direktere Beteiligung an der Sache. Direkt mal umsetzen. Also wir sind die modernste Möglichkeit elektronischer Kommunikation. Wir machen das einfach übers Telefon. 0331 677 9110 ist die Hotline von Fritz. Welche elektronischen Services in Sachen Bürgerbeteiligung würdet ihr euch in dem Fall wünschen? Welche elektronischen Services für euch, damit ihr mit eurer Regierung, eurer Stadt oder was auch immer in Kontakt treten könnt, schweben euch vor? Das ist natürlich eine sehr abstrakte Frage und nicht so einfach zu beantworten aus dem Kalten. Deswegen ist es ganz gut, mal ein paar Beispiele aus der Privatwirtschaft zu bringen.
Genau, letztendlich geht es bei E-Government ja auch nur darum, existierende Prozesse und Strukturen zu verlagern und elektronisch abzuwickeln. Bestes Beispiel in der privaten Wirtschaft ist wahrscheinlich E-Banking, das sehr viele Menschen inzwischen nutzen. Da wurde ja letztendlich nur eine weitere Alternative geschaffen, die sich aber deutlich bewährt hat, nämlich das Abwickeln von Bankgeschäften vom Computer zu Hause, was dazu geführt hat, dass Filialien geschlossen wurden, was dazu geführt hat, dass Personal entlassen wurde, dass das Ganze verschlankt wurde, effizienter wurde und vor allem 24 Stunden am Tag möglich ist. Die Frage, die sich hier stellt, wie kann man das auf Bürgerdienste anbringen, anwenden und welche Konsequenzen hat das?
Hat sich das denn wirklich bewährt im Bankenbereich oder ist das sowas, was sie immer gerne so vorschieben und wo sie sich wünschen würden, dass alle mitmachen oder ist das was, wo wirklich schon mehr Leute sich dran beteiligen?
Kennst du noch Leute, die Überweisungsträger in ihre Band bringen?
Meine Freundin fände man mit dem Fahrrad zum Angriffkasten.
Ich denke, bei diesen Online-Banking-Geschichten ist noch dieser Sicherheitsaspekt ein Problem. Und den haben wir natürlich genauso auch beim E-Government. Das heißt, da ist noch ganz viel Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten, wie denn diese technischen Vorgänge dann gehen. Das heißt, ich kriege dann vielleicht mal so eine Bürgerkarte, wo so eine elektronische Signatur drauf ist, an welche Daten die gesparchelt sind, dann brauche ich irgendwie ein Passwort. Und irgendwie, wie sicher ist denn das, wenn ich das jetzt in meinen PC reinstecke, was passiert denn mit diesen Daten und kann dann vielleicht jemand anders was unterschreiben damit? Und wie gehe ich damit um mit dieser ganzen Problematik? Also wie weit traue ich dieser Technik auch zu, dass sie für mich wirklich zuverlässig arbeitet in meinem Sinne? Also dass nicht in irgendwas nachhinein auf mich zurückfallen kann.
Ich meine, das müsste doch im Grunde was sein, was auch für den normalen Normalbürger im Endeffekt zugänglich ist, wo der auch nicht viel falsch machen kann. Da ist der eine Schlitz, ich habe meine eine Karte, ich muss mir nicht merken.
Es sind Computer dran beteiligt.
Auf jeden Fall, aber der Christian aus Bayern ist am Telefon. Hallo Christian.
Ja hallo.
Was würdest du dir denn wünschen? Wir fragen ja hier wirklich ganz offen jetzt am Anfang der Chaosradio Sendung mal, welche elektronischen Bürgerservices ihr euch wünschen, dann 031 77 97 110. Was schwebt ihr da vor?
Also ich würde persönlich gerne zum Beispiel bei Bundestagswitzungen oder anderen Debatten, die ja öffentlich übertragen werden, einfach meine Ideen und meine Vorschläge selber einbringen können. Dass ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen Bundestagspräsidenten einfach irgendwie eine E-Mail schicken kann und wenn der zumindest findet, dass es irgendwie was Interessantes ist, weil alle wird mir wahrscheinlich etwas vorbringen können, dann würde er das stellvertretend für mich vorbringen oder eine ähnliche Beteiligung.
Die Idee ist gut, die Frage ist, wie man das umsetzt, ob das skaliert in diesem Fall. Also stell dir einfach vor, wir haben den wünschenswerten Zustand, dass die Hälfte der Bundesbevölkerung sich einbringt und es per Mail tut, per Chat noch besser in Echtzeit direkt über.
Ja, wäre eben da eine Möglichkeit, aber man kann eben das vielleicht auch in ein kleines Gremium, das unabhängig ist, einbringen und das Gremium veröffentlichen.
Also die Idee gab es ja schon, auch die Bundesregierung hat ja mal einen Versuch gemacht, das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, über einen Daumen gepeilt, ungefähr ein Jahr, wo so zu bestimmten Themen Diskussionsforen eingerichtet wurden, wo Leute dann tatsächlich auch Sachen von sich geben konnten, schreiben konnten, das war moderiert, dass nicht jeder irgendwelchen Quatschers schreiben kann, aber schon die Sachen, die jetzt irgendwie einen Inhalt hatten, wurden auch veröffentlicht. Und was jetzt aber fehlt, ist quasi so ein Nachweis des Vorgangs, was jetzt mit diesen Sachen passiert ist. Also wer hat die Sachen denn gelesen, wer hat da was darauf reagiert oder so, das ist jetzt das Problem. Also ich meine, ich schreib da jetzt was und ich hab dann aber keinen Rückweg quasi, also ich hab dann nicht keine direkte Reaktion da drauf, ich weiß nicht, was damit jetzt passiert ist.
Das wär natürlich schon praktisch, weil ich dann eben auch nicht die Werte bearbeitete.
Aber wo du sagst, mit dem Gremium, was man dann extra einrichtet, das hört sich dann wieder so ein bisschen so an, dass das DAS Gremium für das Gremium dann es wieder nicht bewältigen kann, dann müssen die ein Untergremium einrichten, das hört sich schon wieder nicht so besonders verschlankend an nach dem direkten Weg, sondern eher so nach, da sitzt dann ein Haufen Sekretärinnen oder besser noch so ein Callcenter extra für deine Mails, die du schickst und die haben dann so Standardgriefe und die passen dir dann so ein bisschen an.
Ich bezweifle eigentlich eh, dass so viele Leute da dran teilnehmen werden. Wenn man sich heute das anschaut, wer liest denn zu einem Bundestagsdebatten mit? Wer schaut sich Bundestagsdebatten im Fernsehen an? Also ich denke, gerade bei vielen wichtigen Punkten ist es einfach so, es interessiert nur keine Minderheit. Die Minderheit, beziehungsweise es interessiert eben nur wenige, aber die können eben ihre Meinung überhaupt nicht einbringen. Bei vielen Themen wäre das wirklich wenig, was da zusammenkommt.
Ich unterstelle aber einfach mal, dass je besser die Möglichkeiten sind für den einzelnen Bürger, sich einzubringen, umso mehr genutzt werden. Ich meine, frag mal die Bürger, warum sie zum Beispiel nicht mal wählen gehen. Naja, das ändert ja eh nichts. Also selbst bei den Wahlen schon, wo es wirklich nur alle vier Jahre ein Kreuz ist, haben die Leute schon die Hoffnung verloren, dass damit irgendwas passiert. Und wenn sie jetzt noch häufiger die Möglichkeit hätten, sich einzubringen und dann auch sehen würden, dass da tatsächlich was passiert, dass es irgendwo ankommt, denke ich schon, dass das Leute ermuntern würde.
Dann würde sie in dem Sinne was bringen. Das würde sie wahrscheinlich regulieren. Weil wenn zu viel ankommt, dann bringt es auch wieder weniger. Vielleicht werden die Leute dann auch merken, dass es bei bestimmten Debatten eben weniger bringt. Außerdem, es ist ja nicht so, dass da jede E-Mail einzeln beantwortet muss. Es reicht im Grunde genommen schon, wenn man Tendenzen hat.
Und Stimmungsbilder erkennen kann. Wobei da die Frage ist, ob man es per Mail abwickelt. Aber was mich unglaublich stört, ist zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, meinen Bundestagsabgeordneten direkt zu erreichen, ist nicht vorgesehen beim Bundestag.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Ich kann da nicht hinkriegen und sagen, ich wohne in dieser Straße. Ich würde gerne wissen, wer für mich zuständig ist. Weil ich muss wissen, wer der Typ ist, seit wann ist.
Du kannst bei dem Bundestag schauen, wer für deinen Wahlkreis zuständig ist.
Das darf schon, das geht.
Über eine Suche. Berlin, Friedrichshain oder so.
Sagt Frank, das geht total einfach Rosengard hier einfach mal so.
Man bekommt für den Abgeordneten eigentlich auch relativ viele Informationen. Und nein, das habe ich gefunden. Das ist alles möglich.
Das wollte ich nämlich mal fragen, weil du klingst ja so, als hättest du dich jetzt nicht bis heute Abend so hingesetzt und dich eingeigelt, sondern schon mal versucht, den Kontakt aufzunehmen. Hast du da schon mal was gemacht und auch ein Feedback bekommen?
Ja, ich habe im Rahmen der Urheberrechtsrichtlinie gemacht. Ich habe gestern mal einfach so die ersten 20 nach dem Alphabet nach einfach mal immer einen gleichen Text geschrieben. Da war die Reaktion mittelmäßig. Da hat es in der Regel mehrere Wochen gedauert, bis ich dann überhaupt da immer gekommen habe. Und die meisten haben eigentlich dann auf den Wirtschaftsausschuss mitgewiesen. Jetzt habe ich vor kurzem bei der zweiten oder dritten Anhörung habe ich mir das Protokollbuch gelesen. Und da habe ich ihm gezielt zu den Leuten Kommentare geschrieben, was im Grunde genommen kommentiert, wie ich das finde, wie ich ihre Meinung finde und so weiter. Das habe ich jetzt abgeschickt und das war letzten Freitag. Ich habe verständlicherweise noch keine Antwort, aber müssen wir schauen, wie das wird.
Aber klingt jetzt schon nicht so wie die Sache, die man zwischen Suppe und Kartoffeln macht. Da muss man sich schon ein bisschen mit drum kümmern, bevor man da jetzt großartig was schreiben kann, oder? Wir haben uns so gerade angeguckt mit dem rechten und mit dem linken Auge, weil wir gleich Nachrichten machen müssen. Wir haben es schon zweieinhalb. Es ist halt so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Und das, was auch rausgekommen ist, ist die Tatsache, dass man sich, wenn man schon mal dann die Zeit investiert und was schreibt, dann auch wünscht, dass man weiß, ob das Ganze mit einem seriösen Auge gelesen worden ist. Weil ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, was du schickst irgendwie so einem Typen, der hat sich da hochgearbeitet, meint, er weiß ein bisschen was von der Materie. Dann schickst du dem eine Mail, schreibst einen Kommentar rein von vier Zeilen, nach dem Motto, du glaubst doch nicht im Ernst, das kannst du ja auch nett machen. Aber woher weiß man, ob der Typ sich das wirklich ernsthaft durchliest und in Erwägung zieht?
Ich versuche es eben durch den Text einigermaßen interessant zu machen, was man so vielleicht irgendwie denn erreichen kann. Es ist eh wahrscheinlich so, dass es bis zur Sekretärin durchgeht und erst dann, wenn die Sekretärin das für wichtig empfindet, dass es weiter geht.
Ich denke auch, dass die Antwort oder dieser Verweis auf den Wirtschaftsausschuss schon recht deutlich zeigt, wie schwach die Zivilgesellschaft in diesem Land noch vertreten ist.
Ja, die Zivilgesellschaft hat leider keine Lobby. Das ist das, was ich immer wieder gerne sage. Wir werden gleich weitertalken im Chaosradio, wie auf Fritz in Blue Moon unter 0-73-97-1-1-0. Vielen Dank dir erstmal, Christian. Tschüss und viel Erfolg und ich hoffe, du bekommst eine Antwort.
Tschüss, mach's gut.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten hier auf Fritz.
Wenn Fritz in Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht bleibt es, das ist doch mal was Schönes, trocken, bei Tiefwerten zwischen 6 und 2 Grad, also relativ kühl. Morgen wird es allerdings genauso schön, wie es heute tagsüber war. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 17 bis 20 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
In Berliner Köln hat es eine tödliche Schisserei gegeben. Dabei wurde ein Brizist getötet, ein weiterer wurde schwer verletzt. Die Brizisten wollten in einer Wohnung einen Mann verhaften, der wegen einer Messerstecherei gesucht wurde. Die drei großen Berliner Unis planen einen totalen Zulassungs- und Einstellungsstopp. Sie regierten damit auf neue Sparpläne von Finanzsenator Sarrazin. Die Humboldt-Uni will schon im kommenden Wintersemester keine Studenten mehr aufnehmen und ab sofort keine Stellen neu besetzen. Im Irak ist eine neue Widerstandsgruppe gegründet worden. Sie nennt sich Irakische nationale Befreiungsorganisation. Die Gruppe hat den bewaffneten Kampf gegen die Alliierten angekündigt. Das Ansehen der Politik hat in Deutschland einen dramatischen Tiefstand erreicht. Noch drei Prozent der Bürger haben Vertrauen in die Arbeit der politischen Parteien. Auch Arbeitsämter und Rentenversicherungen, Bundestag und Gewerkschaften, sowie Kirchen erhielten schlechte Noten. Das geht aus einer heute veröffentlichten Online-Umfrage hervor. Auf Blick auf die Verkehrslage, wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen wünschen.
So, die Beastie Boys dürften das Gehirn nochmal neu gebootet haben, für den Fall, dass ihr gedacht habt, mein Gott, dieser Einstieg in dieses Thema von den Chaos-Radioten, heute aus Computer Club LUMUN auf Schritz. Das war ja nun nicht der einfachste Tobak, den ihr euch hättet aussuchen können. Nein, das ist richtig. Es ist nun nicht so das Thema, wie gefallen euch Hänseln und Gretel 2000 Jahre danach. Aber es ist wichtig für die Zukunft. Das kann man einfach mal sagen. Es ist doch ein Doverspruch. Ich glaube, das hat, das haben meine Lehrer immer schon zu mir gesagt. Das hat mir damals schon nicht gefallen. Das ist wirklich für die Zukunft. Aber das ist schon so ein bisschen wichtig für die Zukunft, oder?
Ich denke, wir setzen da jetzt gerade, solange wir in der Lage sind, in diesem schwammigen Themenbereich, und es ist ja momentan noch, Maßstäbe. Es ist einfach so, dass die Regierung das schon erkannt hat, dass sie das auch als wünschenswert erachten. Auch diese Stichworte schlanker Staatbund 2005, elektronische Verwaltung, da sollte es ja kommen. In zwei Jahren soll das ziemlich heftig losgehen, dass wir jetzt noch in der Lage sind, uns als Zivilgesellschaft einzubringen und das auch tun müssen, um entsprechend den Rahmen abzustecken.
Andreas und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club, meine Person Max, am Mikrofon hier im Fritz Studio. 0371 77 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer, über die ihr euch beteiligen könnt. Stichwort für den Abend heute ist, um einfach noch mal den Einstieg zu liefern, das große E-Business gibt es ja schon, das haben auch alle begriffen, sowohl IBM, als auch Sony, als auch die ganzen großen Firmen. Langsam denken sich die Regierungen, Mensch, also die E-Regierung, das wäre doch auch mal was für uns. Und deswegen ist die große Frage, wie soll man diesen Begriff E-Regierung, E-Government, elektronische Verwaltung, elektronischer Bürger, elektronische Politiker vielleicht auch umsetzen in den nächsten Jahren? Politiker-Bots, Politiker-Bots. Wobei, das ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen kritisch, ich dieses Gefühl habe, dass viele der Politiker nicht mehr als Bots gewesen, sind die letzten Jahre, aber das ist eine persönliche Bemerkung.
Kleiner Literatur-Tipp an der Stelle, Stephen Burey, Interface.
Gut, damit hätten wir das auch geklärt, aber wir haben noch nicht geklärt, was ihr dazu denkt. In der ersten halben Stunde haben wir schon ein paar Stimmen gehört, was ihr euch wünschen würdet an elektronischen Einschlussnahmemöglichkeiten. Das heißt, was hättet ihr gerne auf elektronischem Wege? Was würdet ihr gerne machen mit eurem Start auf elektronischem Wege? Hättet ihr gerne noch mehr an Feedback dazu, was ihr sonst schon so auf Phoenix sehen könnt? Also so eine komplette Bundestagsdebatte mit der Möglichkeit, euch da einzuklikken. Die Idee hatten wir ja gerade schon mal gehabt, aus Bayern, geliefert über Telefon. Wenn ihr ähnliche Ideen habt, 031 70 97 110, die Nummer für heute Abend. Telefon ist erst mal der Rainer. Na, abend Rainer, hallo. Was würdest du dir wünschen? Wir haben hier den großen Wunschzettel.
Ja, also ich würde es gar nicht schlecht finden, wenn man sich zum Beispiel so ummelden könnte oder so direkte Verwaltungsgeschichten, mit denen man hin und her zu tun hat, so Steuererklärungen und so was, wenn man das direkt elektronisch machen könnte.
Bist du aus Berlin oder irgendwo? Das ist so richtig nervig, ne, wenn man da irgendwie zu so einer Meldestelle geht, so eine blöde Nummer ziehen muss, irgendwie drei Stunden vielleicht wartet.
Also man hat manchmal wirklich Glück. Also ich muss dazu sagen, in den letzten Jahren hat sich das echt gebessert. Die Leute sind sowas von nett und freundlich und hilfsbereit. Komisch. Hat sich wirklich was getan, und wollte sich einfach mal ein Lob einstreuen. Auf der anderen Seite, die müssen halt auch das nur im Computer eingeben und das ist ja in dem Sinne, das kannst du auch machen eigentlich. Das würden wir auch selber machen. Also das denke ich, solche Sachen gingen relativ besser. Oder würde ich mir halt wünschen. Ich hab mir jetzt so eine kleine Liste gemacht, dass ich das so hintereinander sagen kann. Also das denke ich wäre ein großer Vorteil, wenn man das einfacher machen könnte.
Zur Steuer, gibt es da schon ein Projekt, das nenne ich AESTER, die elektronische Steuererklärung. Die sind auch relativ aufgeschlossen gegenüber Open Source. Da gab es in der letzten Datensteuer unsere Mitgliederzeitung, glaube ich sogar einen Artikel zu, angekündigt, dass sie selbstverständlich die Spezifikationen veröffentlichen werden. Auch dass es eine Forderung gegenüber dem transparenten Start, dass es eine Prozesse dokumentiert und öffentlich macht, sodass du in der Lage sein wirst, entweder mit vom Start bereitgestellter Software oder mit Software von Drittanbietern oder der große Wunsch mit Open Source Software, bei der du kontrollieren kannst, wer eigentlich deine Daten letztendlich in den Händen hält, sodass vielleicht bei einer Steuererklärung nicht das Falscheste ist. Und elektronische Steuererklärung, denke ich, wird in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft möglich sein.
Ja gut, wäre jetzt halt ein Beispiel. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich natürlich, die Nachteile im Moment noch würden dem überwiegen. Also das elektronisch zu machen oder zum Großteil elektronisch zu machen. Also ich denke mal, ein großer Nachteil wäre, dass nicht wirklich alle Leute, ich meine du und ich vielleicht, aber wirklich nicht alle Leute haben ein Draht zum Internet. Entweder keinen Lust auf Computer, ich sag mal auch ältere Leute, oder einfach Leute, die damit überhaupt keinen Umgang haben. Denke ich, das ist eine ganze Menge im Ganzen gesehen. Und wenn ich schon sehe, wie sich manche Leute an diesen Bankcomputern da schwer tun, weil sie es einfach nicht, ja, sich auch nicht reinfummeln möchten oder das irgendwie nicht begreifen, sondern einfach noch das Guten Tag am Schalter hören wollen, okay, denke ich so auf einen Großteil der Bevölkerung ist da ein bisschen vielleicht nicht ganz so offen. Wenn wir aber selbst von ausgehen, dass, sag ich mal, fast alle online wären, denke ich, ist es nicht wirklich sicher. Und gerade im Bereich, wo es halt persönliche Daten angeht, Bankverbindungen, komme ich auch schon ein bisschen entschwimmen. Also ich habe zwar diesen Zugang mit PIN und TAN und diese alle heißen, für Kontobewegungen, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, wenn ich da schon höre, dass diese Einwahlgeschichten mit den 0790-Nummern so leicht geknackt wurden und da so viele Minen reingelegt wurden, also ein Arbeitskollege von mir, der hat auch irgendwie sich da gerade 3500 Euro wohlgemerkt in der Haare mit seinem Telefonanbieter über irgendwelche Einwahlnummern und der ist wirklich einer, den ich so einschätze, der sich da wirklich nicht in irgendwelche Systeme einloggt, um da ein paar Bildchen zu gucken. Also das kann wirklich jedem passieren, wenn man da nicht wirklich, ich sag mal, auch Glück hat. Ich meine, der eine hat eine Firewall, von dem, von dem funktioniert oder funktioniert nicht und wenn dann gerade zufällig jemand in die Lücke trifft, dann ist man halt dran und es ist sehr, sehr schwer nachzuweisen, ob man was oder was man nicht gemacht hat. Und so denke ich, ist das auch bei den elektronischen Signaturen.
Hast du denn die Idee, was der Staat tun könnte, um das Vertrauen zu steigern oder vielleicht die wirkliche Sicherheit auch zu steigern?
Naja, die Sicherheit, es gibt ja diverse Verschlüsselungsprogramme und Codierungsmöglichkeiten, aber ich sag mal, generell einfache Sachen, die man eben wirklich machen kann, wo die Daten bekannt sind. Ich sag mal, wenn ich beim Finanzamt anrufe, sagt das die Steuernummer, wunderbar, dann kann man da was hin und her schicken. Das kann man auch mit so einem persönlichen Schlüssel machen. Bei Neuanmeldung und sowas. Oder wenn ich jetzt irgendwo hinziehe, würde ich das schon favorisieren, wenn man das persönlich machen muss. Weil dann ist eben jemand da. Irgendwie diese Karten mit Passfoto oder eben nicht, wo man halt sehen kann, okay, das ist der wirklich. Und kann nicht jeder einfach hin oder irgendwie mit einem Code oder ich weiß nicht, ich bin da im Computer an sich auch nicht so fit. Ich kann halt nur sehen, was alles passiert und sagen, okay, also das passt mir jetzt nicht oder das wäre mir zu unsicher, irgendwelche wichtigen Geschichten einfach so über die Elektronik machen zu lassen.
Das ist ein guter Ansatz. Würdest du das, hab ich das richtig verstanden, würdest du das zum Beispiel vom Haftungsrisiko abhängig machen? Also auch sagen, Dinge niederer Bedeutung kann ich auf elektronischen Wegen abwickeln. Dinge, die zum Beispiel Identitätsdiebstahl erlauben würden, weil ich mir eine neue digitale Identität schaffe, indem ich das erste Mal meinen elektronischen Ausweis beantrage. Möchte ich bitte weiterhin auf herkömmlichen Weg machen?
Das würde ich schon favorisieren, auf jeden Fall. Und da auch eine deutliche Unterscheidung, auch in dem, was für jemand anders interessant sein kann. Weil ich meine, allein diese Geschichten mit Visa-Kart-Nummern, wenn da jemand fit ist und sich irgendwie sowas rauslesen kann, kann er damit alle möglichen Bilder machen. Es wird aber keiner daran Interesse haben, irgendwie so grob mal gesagt Fahrzeug, wir ziehen jetzt um, legen das von da nach da, einfach eine Ummeldung, oder ich bin jetzt umgezogen, oder wie auch immer, was man halt postalisch, also wirklich mechanisch nochmal überprüfen kann, oder nochmal gegenstemmeln kann, oder jetzt nicht gerade Fax schicken, aber per Brief von Hand geschrieben, denke ich, dass es nicht ganz so interessant wäre, für irgendjemand sich da einzumischen. Ich meine, wenn ich von irgendjemanden eine Nummer hätte, von so einer Visa-Card, bis so was rauskommt, sage ich mal, bis das gebucht ist, dann wird Ware zugestellt, dann bekommt man irgendwie die Rechnung, oder wird dann das Konto belastet, das dauert dann vielleicht zwei Wochen, und in der Zeit kann man im Prinzip, wenn man es wirklich drauf anlegen würde, eine Menge Blödsinn mitmachen, und dass es immer wieder Leute gibt, die es drauf anliegen, das ist ja nur weit bekannt.
Aber Rainer ist ja eigentlich merkwürdig, weil wir reden ja gerade auch darüber, was in diesem Bereich auch mit der Regierung und all den Sachen, die uns auf dem Verwaltungswege betrifft, was man da so machen könnte, das, worüber wir jetzt reden, nämlich dass es irgendwo um Geld gehen könnte, das uns verloren geht, das kann uns ja jetzt schon verloren gehen, weil wir haben genau das haben wir umgesetzt.
Das stimmt, ein bisschen abgeschritten. Also ich sag mal, die nächste Geschichte für die Regierung wäre natürlich, würde eine Menge Beamte arbeitslos werden, denke ich. Wäre vielleicht schade drum, je nachdem wie schnell man das umsetzt. Wenn man das natürlich so auslaufen lässt, zu sagen, ja gut, die die ja sowieso in Rente gehen, das wird eben nicht nachgesetzt, sondern da kann man dann eben die Leute einsparen, dann wäre das ja längerfristig, mehr oder weniger gruppierbar, dann wäre das in Ordnung.
Wobei im Moment eigentlich die Sorge der Beschäftigten eher eine andere ist. Wir haben im Moment Sorge, dass mit zunehmender Transparenz und irgendwelchen Informationsfreiheits-Gesetzen, sag ich gleich noch was zu, was da ist, je mehr das kommt, desto mehr Arbeit sehen die auf die zukommen, weil plötzlich die Bürger alle plötzlich dastehen und sagen sie, was machen sie, da erklären sie das jetzt mal. Das will ich jetzt aber hier irgendwie schriftlich und da will ich jetzt aber auch nochmal eine Kopie von haben. Und die sehen das nicht so, dass sie irgendwie überflüssig werden, sondern die sehen plötzlich ganz viel Arbeit auf die Zukunft. Sie sehen, dass in der Übergangszeit alles doppelt machen, das nämlich auf Papier und ins System eingeben. Klar, längerfristig natürlich schon, aber im Moment bedeutet das für die Verwaltung auf jeden Fall, also zumindestens eine große Umstellung und wenn nicht sogar deutlich mehr Arbeit.
Das ist eine rein organisatorische Sache. Ich sag mal so, weil ob, Vergleich fällt mir ein mit dem Euro, da hat man gesagt so, ab dann und dann funktioniert das so und so, dann haben wir das und dann müssen alle mit umgehen und ich sag mal, wir haben ein selbstregulierendes System, denke ich, da wird schon jeder irgendwie mit klarkommen. Da muss man halt nochmal nachlesen.
Dosenpfand Rainer.
Zum Beispiel, ich mein, ich finde es persönlich lästig, unterm Strich denke ich, ist die Idee gar nicht schlecht, aber unterm Strich, man hat gesehen, der eine hat sein Material komplett aus dem Sortiment genommen, der nächste macht seinen eigenen Firmenaufkleber drauf und dann kann man es an jeder Filiale tauschen und die Nächsten fangen an mit Kassenbongs und wenn einmal irgendwie, wenn man nicht bei der Filiale, sag ich mal, nachts zum Beispiel das wieder abgibt, wo man es zufällig eingekauft hat, weil man gerade da in der Gegend war und noch Lust auf ein Getränk hatte, dann steht man da und muss es hinterher wieder bezahlen. Gut, das ist natürlich eine Geschichte, der eine kriegt es besser geregelt und der andere nicht. Da muss man sich natürlich ein bisschen Gedanken vorher machen.
Das ist aber trotzdem...
Das war sehr überstürzt und die Wirtschaft, sag ich mal, hatte nicht großartig Zeit. Gut hat man gesehen, wer flexibel war. Ich meine, ich finde es schlimm, ich persönlich.
Das war trotzdem ein sehr anschauliches Beispiel, denke ich, für letztendlich, dass der Bürger der Leid tragende politischen Handelns ist.
Das sind wir ja immer.
Und was wir ohnehin immer sind, aber das muss man schön feststellen, und auch welche Interessensgruppen am politischen Prozess beteiligt sind und dass die Zivilgesellschaft halt in der Regel fehlt.
Ich meine, wenn wir mal tachelos reden hier am Telefon, so eine richtige Meinungsfreiheit, denke ich, oder Entscheidungsgewalt, glaube ich persönlich, haben wir sowieso nicht mehr. Das ist, wie gesagt jetzt mal unter Meinungsfreiheit, ist jetzt nicht so ganz das Thema. Aber ich denke auch gerade mit elektronischer E-Government so richtig das, was man hören möchte, das wird man da nicht mehr rauslesen können als aus den Bundestagsdebatten live übertragen zum Beispiel. Oder wenn man wirklich hinterher ist, sich Informationen zu besorgen, dann bekommt man die auch mehr oder weniger schwierig. Und da sieht man schon, wie das ein bisschen ausgesiegt wird, denke ich.
Aber was der Frank vorhin gesagt hat, das ist ja eigentlich der springende Punkt. Wenn die Angst davor haben, dass sie auf einmal den Leuten all das erklären müssen, das ist doch im Grunde das, was ich erwarte. Ich möchte doch gerne, dass ich da hinschreiben kann, sagen kann, Entschuldigen Sie mal, Frau Müller, sagen Sie mir doch mal, warum das überhaupt so ist. Den Service will ich doch haben.
Ja, ich sag mal, den Service, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen blöd. Ich würde auch nicht irgendwie frech wirken, aber das wollen wir doch alle. Wenn wir mal gucken, was wir wirklich an Informationen kriegen, auf offizieller Seite, wenn man sich das nicht zufällig irgendwo hintenrum Informationen gesorgt, kriegt man teilweise von der Politik ein ziemlich falsches Bild, denke ich. Oder auch von Meinungen, oder das wird auch getunt in eine bestimmte Richtung, was der Staat eben gerade möchte oder was für den Staat wichtig ist. Und ich denke nicht, dass es dadurch besser wird, dass man sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt die ganzen Sachen, die kann man elektronisch nachlesen, weil das System an sich sicher nicht komplett 100 Prozent in die Karten schauen lassen möchte, denke ich so. Also in dem Sinne wäre es kein direkter Vorteil, weil wenn irgendwas schief läuft, ich sag mal, ich habe als Beispiel einen Sachbearbeiter im Finanzamt, oder wo auch immer, der macht Mist. So, dann kann ich jetzt hingehen, dann kann ich mich bei seinem Vorgesetzten beschweren, aber unterm Strich, wenn der mir irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 1000 Mark zu viel abzieht, oder Euro, und ich hab dann irgendein Problem damit, jetzt als Beispiel oder damit Schere rein, ich krieg den ja nicht. Und ich krieg den elektronisch auch nicht, der macht grad so weiter, der sagt vielleicht, du, tut mir leid, aber ich sag mal, effektiv passiert nichts. Wenn ich jetzt selber irgendeinen Mist mache, steuern zu wenig zahle oder was, das gibt einen Höllenärger. Und die Leute in den Regionen können sich eben andere Sachen erlauben, denke ich einfach mal. Dadurch, dass man elektronisch nachfragen könnte, oder mal sagen würde, so und so, dann mal eine Mail hinschreiben, mach mal das und das, oder wie sieht denn das und das aus, dann kriegt man dann vielleicht einen Kommentar, wird bearbeitet und dann hört man zu ihrer nichts mehr von.
Das bringt uns aber denke ich noch mal zu diesem Transparenzargument, dass es schon hilfreich wird, wenn man eben vergleichbare Fälle hat und die elektronisch einsehen kann und es für die Verwaltung auch schwieriger wird, einen Fall untergehen zu lassen oder auch für, wie noch immer, schwieriger wird, gewisse Themen auszuklammern, weil es so ist, dass grundsätzlich alles erst mal dokumentiert wird, was der Idealfall wäre, wenn es klappen könnte, und es dann im Einzelfall begründet werden muss, warum denn nun konkret dieser Punkt nicht dokumentiert ist, als wenn die im jetzigen System ich grundsätzlich eine Anfrage stellen muss, um überhaupt erstmal Informationen zu bekommen.
Wer an sich nicht verkehrt, ich sage mal, alles was dem Bürger unterm Strich dazu hilft, oder dabei hilft, Informationen zu bekommen oder seine eigenen Rechte mal gegenüber dem Stark wirklich durchzusetzen, ist natürlich nur positiv. Ich denke aber an sich, dass das System, so wie wir es ja auch in der Politik haben, man wird nie an jemanden kommen, der einem eine Miene legt, gegen die man effektiv was machen kann. Das fängt, soll jetzt nicht politisch werden, fängt ein bisschen mit dem Rechtssystem an und tut über die eigentlichen Entscheidungen weiter. Ich sag mal, wir zahlen Steuern ohne Ende, als Beispiel, um das ein bisschen ansichtig zu machen. Wir zahlen Steuern. Und für alle Sachen, wenn ich irgendwo hingehe, ich sag mal Bürgerrechte und Personalausweisanträge, sage ich, ich ziehe um, ich zahle jedes Mal noch eine Gebühr. Wofür zahle ich denn Steuern? Als Beispiel.
Das wäre zum Beispiel mal interessant, den Geldfluss dann auch nachvollziehen zu können.
Ja, sehr schön. Dann sagen die, das ist jetzt darauf geschrieben. Ich meine, gerade hier in Berlin gucken wir uns mal um. Wenn man zweimal durch Wettzeitstand gefahren ist, wird einem deutlicher Unterschied auffallen. Wir zahlen alle Kraftfahrzeugsteuern, Kraftstoffsteuer, Sprit und Diesel und weiß ich nicht was, ohne Ende und unsere Straßen sehen aus wie die letzten Baustellen allesamt. Also ich meine, man kann natürlich ständig Geld für neue Stoßdämpfer ausgeben und neue Reifen, aber wo geht das Geld hin? Und ich denke nicht, dass es dadurch durchsichtiger wird, dass man das elektronischer macht.
Also es gibt in Berlin das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst. Das ist eine Sache, die bundesweit durchgesetzt werden soll. Es ist so, dass du als Berliner die Möglichkeit hast, nicht die Möglichkeit, sondern das Recht dazu hast, bei einer Verwaltung nachzufragen, was macht ihr da? Und ich will jetzt bitte Kopien von meinen Akten haben, was da liegt, und ich will wissen, wie das jetzt alles gelaufen ist. Das heißt Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, gibt es Informationen dazu unter www.informationsfreiheit.de. Da haben die Datenschutzbeauftragten Informationen zusammengetragen. Das bundesweit zu vereinheitlichen, da gibt es Widerstände aus verschiedenen Bundesländern, vor allem aber auch von den Bundesbehörden, zum Beispiel dem Verteidigungsministerium, dem Wirtschaftsministerium, Ministerium für Inneren. Klar, das sind die natürlich, wo auch besonders reiche Sachen an Akten sind. Und diese Informationsfreiheitsgesetze sehen eigentlich auch vor, dass es praktisch keine Ausnahmen gibt, nur sehr wenige Ausnahmen gibt von Akten, die jetzt nicht rausgegeben werden dürfen. Also zum Beispiel die, wo personenbezogene Daten oder personenbeziehbare Daten enthalten sind. Oder Sachen, wo jetzt die Bundesregierung, nicht die Regierung, sondern die Bundesrepublik Deutschland als solches gefährdet wäre. Also jetzt irgendwelche wirklich sicherheitsrelevante Sachen.
Nein, nein, das soll ja auch so bleiben. Also ich weiß nicht so recht an der Stelle. Zum Teil hab ich mal durchgeguckt. Hier sag ich mal Bundesregierung.de ist das, glaube ich. Da sind sehr viele Seiten, die sind sehr interessant. Die finde ich wirklich sehr gut. Und da kann man auch wirklich eine Menge nachlesen. Mit den Freiheiten. Gut, ich hab's persönlich noch nicht getestet. Ich hab mir das mal notiert. Bei Gelegenheit werd ich da auch gerne mal reinschnuppern. Und mal irgendwie eine Frage stellen. Mal gucken, was drauf kommt. Man muss ja alles testen. Also wenn's das gibt, ich mein, es gibt viele Gesetze, ob sind wir ganz so... Ich bin da beim juristischen System auf der Seite ein bisschen persönlich jetzt, ein bisschen am Schwimmen, ob das alles so hinhaut. Am Strich haben wir das hier sehr gut. Aber so ganz endgültig in die Karten lassen, gucken möchte sich da glaube ich doch keiner denken.
Das ist doch mal ein schönes Schlussstatement. Jetzt haben wir uns ja auf ganz vielen Gebieten heiß geredet und wir merken auch schon, wie ganz viele Leute zu verschiedenen Themen, die wir jetzt alle mal angeschnitten haben, anrufen. Vielen Dank erst mal Rainer, das war schon sehr umfangreich. Wir können anrufen weiterhin beim Chaosradio 073 97 110. Wir legen uns hier jetzt auch erst mal kurz zurück und halten die Bubble an, damit ihr auch in euch gehen könnt und vielleicht den ein oder anderen Beitrag leisten könnt, dann auch, wenn ihr euch gesammelt habt. Ihr dürft sich aufschreiben, hat der Rainer auch gemacht. Es ist ausdrücklich erlaubt und macht das Ganze für euch und für uns natürlich und für die Hörer in Berlin und Brandenburg ein bisschen einfacher zu diesem Thema. Welche elektronischen Services für den Bürgerwillen wir euch wünschen. Hier hat das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir haben es genau 23 Uhr und machen nochmal ein akustisches Hallo. Wir sind im Studio von Chaos Computer Club Andreas und Frank, meine Person von Fritz Max von Malotsky. Wir haben noch zwei Stunden Zeit und so wie es aussieht, werden wir alle langsam warm in Berlin und Brandenburg mit diesem Thema. Wir können ja einfach Andreas vielleicht nochmal kurze Einführung machen, wo wir momentan auch sind von der Diskussion her, damit diejenigen, die gerade jetzt eingestellt haben, so wissen worum es geht und was wir schon so vielleicht angehakt haben.
Wir sprechen heute über E-Government. Das ist die Übertragung von Dienstleistungen des Staates zum Bürger oder dessen Verlagerung ins Netz, was wir auch in der Wirtschaft am Beispiel des Home- und Online-Banken gesehen haben. Auf der anderen Seite aber auch, was ja das Selbstverständnis demokratischer Regierungen berührt, die Informationsfreiheit gegenüber den Bürgern, also die Dokumentation der Prozesse der Regierung gegenüber den interessierten Bürgern, was es ja eigentlich sein sollte.
Lässt sich lustigerweise in einer Hand von Sätzen zusammenfassen, aber wenn man daran geht, das umsetzen zu wollen, dann werden die Sätze auf einmal länger. Und deswegen haben wir auch drei Stunden heute Abend im Chaosradio auf Fritz, um darüber zu sprechen. Ausgehen möchten wir mal zumindest noch für ein paar Minuten von der Frage, welche elektronischen Services ihr euch denn wünschen werdet, oder was ihr gerne auf elektronischen Wege erledigt haben möchtet. Wobei wir schon so ein bisschen aufgetan haben heute Abend, dass da eine Menge Probleme dran hängen. Und wenn ihr die seht, also wenn ihr sagt, hey, wenn das und das so und so gehen sollte, wie zum Beispiel, dass ich meinen Ausweis elektronisch beantragen kann oder umziehen kann, elektronisch und ähnliches, dann sehe ich aber die und die und die Probleme und die sind wichtig zu bedenken, dann könnt ihr die auch zur Sprache bringen. 031 70 97 110 ist die Fritz Hotline. Da könnt ihr euch melden, einfach anrufen und wir werden dann zusammen sprechen. Ihr könnt aber auch, wenn ihr möchtet, wenn ihr irgendwie größere Beiträge zum Thema haben möchtet und hinterher noch ein paar Infos haben wollt, eine Mail schreiben an 81, also 8 und 1, atchaosradio.ccc.de für Fragen und Hinweise zu genau dieser Sendung, die dann aber erst nachbeantwortet werden, wenn die Sendung zu Ende ist. Und da können wir, weil wir die volle Stunde haben, auch ruhig nochmal sagen, Frank, dass morgen der Datenblatt wartet.
Genau, das ist eine Veranstaltung, die wir einmal im Monat machen, im Carsten-Hüter-Club in Berlin, in der Marienstraße 11 im Hinterhaus. Da wollen wir eigentlich so ein bisschen das Thema nachbereiten. Also wir müssen mal gucken, wie viele Leute da kommen, in welchem Rahmen wir das machen können. Aber wir würden uns eigentlich freuen, wenn wir direkt mit euch, Hörern, vor Ort die Sache nochmal weiter diskutieren können, weil in so einer gemütlichen Runde diskutiert sich es meist noch ein bisschen besser und produktiver als hier im Radio.
Na, das ist ja ketzerisch. Das ist ja total gemütlich hier, muss ich jetzt einfach mal sagen als Radiomann. Also ich fühle mich wohl und akustisch, das hätte natürlich total eingebettet, auch was unsere tolle Hintergrundmusik anbelangt. Aber ihr könnt wie gesagt auch morgen euch körperlich dahingehende begeben und da mitdiskutieren.
20 Uhr.
Kostet keinen Eintritt und wird wohl eine schnuckelige Runde da.
Eine schnuckelige Runde, na dann ist ja alles in Ordnung. Ihr könnt aber auch jetzt anrufen, weil dafür ist der Abend ja heute auch da, um hier zu talken auf Fritz, 0370 97 110 und am Telefon ist der Bernd aus Potsdam, Name Bernd. Bernd ist noch da. Schade. Schade, denn da ging es so ein bisschen in Richtung, dass Gesetze zur Verfügung stehen sollen, wahrscheinlich auch Diskussionen über Gesetze. Wenn ihr in die Richtung gehen möchtet, was die Diskussion anbelangt, könnt ihr ja in Bernds Kerbe schlagen, die er leider selber noch nicht vertiefen konnte, weil er gar nicht mehr dran ist. Aber der Markus ist vielleicht am Telefon.
Hallo Markus. Hi Markus.
Jo, ich wollte was zum Thema E-Demokratie sagen. Ich wollte eben was sagen, aber ich glaube, dass E-Demokratie wurde vorhin schon gesagt, dass immer nur ein kleiner Teil der Bevölkerung sich für irgendwelche Gesetze und so weiter interessiert. Ich finde, das sollte man viel tiefer auffängen. Also zum Beispiel auf kommunaler Ebene gibt es sehr viele Chancen, eine elektronische Demokratie durchzuführen und zum Beispiel Bürger an Bebauungsvorhaben bei der Planung ihres eigenen Viertels und so weiter mehr einzubeziehen als bisher. Und das muss eigentlich auch von den Politikern als Chance genommen werden, von außen viel mehr Input zu bekommen. Da muss natürlich auch noch eine ganze Menge Sinneswandel bei den Politikern stattfinden. Aber man sollte halt die E-Demokratie nicht immer sofort auf Sozialgesetzgebung oder sonstige Gesetzgebung irgendwie aufziehen, weil um es dahin zu bringen, dauert es wohl noch einige Jahre. Aber auf den unteren Strukturen gibt es so viele Möglichkeiten, die sollten genutzt werden.
Würdest du das als Pull oder als Pushdienst machen wollen? Das heißt also, sollen die Bürger aktiv sich da eindringen oder sollen sie quasi gefragt werden wie bei Wahlen?
Also ob man jetzt, die laufen nur irgendwelche kommunalen Wahlen durchzieht zu einzelnen Themen oder generell die Ideen der Bürger verwendet. Das sind ja zwei verschiedene Dinge. Also die Ideen der Bürger, die in ihrem Viertel leben, die sollten eigentlich als Chance genutzt werden von den Politikern, ihre Arbeit zu verbessern und generell die Arbeit oder die Lebensqualität von allen zu fördern.
Aber Markus, sehr so lieb, weil das natürlich auch kommunale Ebenen hört sich jetzt so einfach an, aber was genau meinst du damit? Vielleicht mal ein paar Beispiele, weil ich weiß, so das beliebteste Beispiel ist die Frage, soll der Grünstreifen auf der Hauptstraße jetzt zwei oder drei Meter breit sein? Klar, das ist greifbar, aber was könnte da noch alles stattfinden? Weil das ist auch so das Einzige, was mir präsent ist.
Ja, die Bebauungsszene ist natürlich das Erste, was wahrscheinlich auch ausprobiert werden wird, weil viele Anlieger dann immer kippt, die dazu Stellung nehmen möchten. Und das ist bisher immer über irgendeinen schriftlichen Wege. Man schreibt ein Papier an die örtliche Verwaltung und man weiß gar nicht, was damit passiert und so weiter. Das könnte man über Foren abwickeln. Zum Beispiel, wie es halt der Bund schon mit elektronisches, mit demokratie.de letztes Jahr getan hat, was aber meiner Meinung nach nicht angenommen wurde, weil da eine, finde ich, schlechte Technik in das stand. Also für die, die sich das angeguckt haben, das war ein Lotus-Notsystem dahinter und die Seiten brauchten irgendwie 10, 20 Sekunden zum Laden, wenn sie mal geladen haben. Und da war natürlich der ganze Spaß von vornherein vorbei. Und das hat die Regierung auch nur getan, weil es halt gesponsert wurde und da hat man sich die Technik nicht ausgesucht. Aber ja, großer Fehler damals. Das wird halt immer als Referenzobjekt sozusagen genutzt.
Aber weil du das hier anfühlst, Markus, was würdest du dir so wünschen? Also was hast du im Hinterkopf, wo du auf kommunaler Ebene, du wohnst in Pankow, Berlin, was würdest du dir in deiner Gegend gerne wünschen? Also wo würdest du sagen, da hätte ich gerne was mit geredet oder das würde ich mir wünschen? Hast du da auch ein paar Sachen auf der Pfanne? Weil das wäre ja das Wichtige.
Ja, zum Beispiel Jugendparlamente, Kinder- und Jugendparlamente, die es schon in verschiedenen Kommunen in Deutschland gibt, wo die sich hier partizipieren können, das Ganze mal spielerisch lernen können, wie man sich als Staatsbürger engagiert.
Diese Kinder-
und Jugendparlamente könnte man auf Internet irgendwie aussehen, dass es generell auch, hey, auf was wo Jugendliche auch hingehen, anstatt zu solchen Kinder- und Jugendparlamenten, wo dann mal kurz der Bürgermeister mit dem Demokraten da steht und alles schön anlächelt. Und da könnte man die Jugendlichen und Kinder fragen, was möchten sie in ihrem Kiez verändert haben? Was sind ihre Bedürfnisse? Und allein auch schon mal so eine Erhebung zu machen, was die Bedürfnisse der Bürger sind und diese Ideen hineinzutragen in die Verwaltung, die Leute den ganzen Tag in ihren Schreibtischen sitzen und irgendwelche Haushalte verplanen. In diese Richtung könnte das gehen.
Aber welche Verbindlichkeit sollen sie vorn haben? Also ich meine, sollen die Politiker oder die Entscheider, die Sachbearbeiter in irgendeiner Form daran gebunden sein, davon was zu verwerten?
Das wäre natürlich optimal so. Das ist natürlich ein Prozess, der sich über verschiedene Meilensteine hin bewegt. Man kann nicht sofort irgendwie die ganze Verwaltung umstellen, aber es muss erstmal die Bereitschaft da sein, von außen oder von der Zivilgesellschaft Input entgegenzunehmen. Und dann muss es auch mittelfrisch darum gehen, irgendwie den Einfluss der Zivilgesellschaft auf die Entscheide oder Entscheidungen generell zu verstärken.
Aber was dabei rauskommt, haben wir gesehen bei der Frage um Software-Patente auf EU-Ebene. Da gab es ja ganz viel, da haben sie gesagt, okay, wir wollen jetzt die ganzen Interessensverbände alle anhören. Und dann haben sie hinterher gesagt, okay, es ist ja schön, dass da irgendwie ganz viel Input gekommen ist, aber das kommt ja eh sowieso alles aus einer Richtung und es ist ja irgendwie ganz klar, welche Interessen da sind und wir entscheiden es jetzt wahrscheinlich doch anders. Oh, schön, danke.
Da müssten eigentlich auch die Politiker hingehen und irgendwie das Ganze einbämmen. Was das Europäische Patentsamt da so macht.
Aber zum Beispiel das mit diesen Foren, das hört sich relativ locker an, aber im Grunde müsste man doch auch gewährleisten können und dann sind wir wieder bei der technischen Seite, dass das repräsentativ ist, was da steht. Das heißt, ich muss da sicher gehen können, dass nicht irgendein Interessengruppe dieses Forum für sich missbraucht und sich dann 15.000 Nicknames macht und dann so zu tun, als würden sowohl Petra, als auch Claudia, als auch Robert wollen, dass der grünen Streifen drei Meter breit wird, sondern dass man ganz genau weiß, das ist Claudia, die wohnt auch in Pankow, die ist da ansässig und die hat damit auch was zu tun. Das ist die Claudia und die kann die Meinung abgeben und keine andere.
Ja, dann bräuchte man natürlich Smartcard oder TCPA oder sonst irgendetwas, die da kennen, da wieder irgendwie Datenschutzbedenken. Also ich finde nicht, dass das Ganze irgendwie an eine Identität gebunden sein müsste. Das müsste generell um diese ähm, um die Diskussion gehen, um halt neue Ideen aufzunehmen und generell das Ganze aus diesen Verwaltungen irgendwie raustragen in die Gesellschaft noch mit rein. Also diese Vermixung von irgendwie Behörden, Verwaltungen und halt den Ideen der Zivilgesellschaft. Da müssen neue Wege gegangen werden und die Möglichkeit ist da. Es gibt ja diese ganzen Ideen von Athen, wie die damals Demokratie gemacht haben. Das war einfach möglich, weil die alle irgendwie in einem begrenzten Areal da waren und sich einfach treffen konnten und diese Möglichkeit gibt es auch im Internet. Also das heißt halt nicht, dass jetzt jeder über jedes Thema abstimmen soll. Aber ich finde, jeder sollte zumindest jetzt schon die Möglichkeit haben zu jedem Thema, wenn er der Meinung ist, dass er dazu was sagen kann, irgendwie die Meinung auch zu sagen. Und das sollte auch in diese ganzen Prozesse hineinkommen.
Indem man drastisch die Hemmschwelle für Beteiligung abbaut, respektive Feldversuche dort, mache ich das richtig verstanden habe, wo die Hemmschwelle gering ist, wie beispielsweise kommunale Beteiligung.
Die Hemmschwelle ist nicht gering, aber da hat sie am meisten oder am schnellsten die Möglichkeit, ja, etwas zu erschaffen.
Effekte, ja.
Effekte. Und da kann man auch am besten die Beteiligung der Zivilgesellschaft, die schon vorhanden ist in den Kommunen, einbinden. Also es ist ja schon heutzutage so, dass in irgendwelchen langweiligen Kommunalratssitzungen Vertreter der Zivilgesellschaft sein, Bürgeranlieger oder sonst die auch hinkommen. Aber da gehen natürlich eine bestimmte Zielgruppe hin, oder eine bestimmte Zielgruppe, die sich darauf einlassen möchte. Aber da geht nicht hin zum Kunstsinn sozusagen, der irgendwelche Ideen hat.
Aber liegt das nicht so ein bisschen daran, dass Politik von der, also wir reden jetzt über das Medium, aber dass Politik so von der Sache her einfach auch nicht wirklich populär ist? Weil wenn ich eben, wenn ich auf irgendeiner komischen Filmwettseite die Frage, die Multiple-Choice-Frage sehe, welcher ist der beste Film mit Harrison Ford, dann hab ich da fünf Filme und dann soll ich mal einen aussuchen. Natürlich krieg ich das irgendwie an. Ich glaube, ich würde mich auch freuen, wenn ich einer fragen würde, wohin soll der Kanzler nächstes Wochenende kommen? Leipzig, Berlin, Frankfurt oder, oder dahin?
Und dann hat man die Macht zu sagen, ich will den Kanzler in Leipzig. Das wär doch toll.
Also die Idee fand ich grad nicht total.
Ja, du willst ihn natürlich gerne in Berlin haben. Aber, nee, aber man kann das natürlich runterbrechen, ist ja die Kunst. Dass alle Leute auch einen Sinn darin sehen, da jetzt irgendwas zu machen und nicht unbedingt so einen Text lesen müssen, der so schwierig ist.
Welcher Text?
Na, einfach die Sache an sich ist viel zu schwierig verkauft. Wenn du nicht mal die Texte verstehst, wenn die Jungs, die dir im Bundestag am Pult vorlesen, dann wirst du die wahrscheinlich auch nicht verstehen, wenn du dir das erste Mal, wenn du ins Internet gehst, an einem Monitor durchliest und da stehen dann zehn Seiten Papier in diesem Beamtendeutsch abgefasst. Wie sollst du dich da beteiligen können?
Na, da könnte man ja vielleicht das neue Urhebergesetz als Desh-Animation irgendwie bringen.
Genau, das ist eine kleine Figur. Bitte gestalten Sie das Urheberrechtsgesetz als kleine Figur. Das machen die dann als Wettbewerb. Ja, okay, wir schweifen ab. Markus, aber danke für deinen Beitrag.
Bitteschön. Das Jugendparlament, nicht das Jugendparlament, aber so eine Idee oder einen Ansatz von diesem Jugendparlament gibt es in Berlin, ein Projekt, das heißt Jugendforum. Und das fand irgendwie gerade im März dieses Jahres statt. Irgendwie zum dritten Mal. Und da haben Jugendliche dann die Möglichkeit, auch mit Politikern mal zu reden, aber mal so richtig ein bisschen quasi Abgeordnete zu spielen. Also die müssen halt auch Sachen diskutieren, kriegen Aufgaben, Problemen stellen, und wie sie bearbeiten. Und können dann auch mal sehen, wie das denn so ist, in welchen Spannungsfeldern Abgeordnete sind.
Die Politikwissenschaftler der Freien Universität Berlin übrigens auch, die machen immer einmal im Jahr ein Seminar und dann werden diese ganzen Studenten, die da sind, verpflichtet, glaube ich, Politiker auf europäischer Ebene zu personifizieren und ein paar von denen spielen dann auch Leute, die in den Medien arbeiten, das heißt, die Journalisten sind und die müssen dann während dreier Tage, wo es einen bestimmten Ernstfall gibt, wie der zum Beispiel Krieg, müssen die einen versuchen, das zu verhindern, die anderen müssen eben halt ihre Argumentation machen und einige tun auch so, als würden sie eine Fernsehsendung darüber produzieren und Ähnliches. Finde ich auch sehr spannend. Brauchen die natürlich ein Semester für, um das Ganze zu verstehen und einigermaßen klar hinzukriegen und jetzt sind Studenten, die sich damit beschäftigen. Dann kann man mal sehen, wie tief die Materie ist. Also, dass der Normalmensch das in einem Forum versteht, ist schon relativ schwierig. Gibt es da irgendwo Ergebnisse, die man nachlesen kann aus diesem Jugendforum? www.berliner-jugendforum.de Okay, kann man ja einfach mal nachgucken, wenn man Interesse daran hat. Ihr könnt aber auch anrufen unter 033 47 97 110, was ihr auf elektronischem Wege erledigen würdet oder was eben halt nicht so erledigt werden sollte und wie man sich vielleicht emanzipieren kann als Bürger in Sachen Politik auf diesem Wege. Darum geht es heute Abend im Chaosradio. Und am Telefon ist der Henning, namens Henning. God damn it, was ist denn heute schon wieder los? Wir sind alle so leise, aber das ist wahrscheinlich daran, dass wir gar nicht mehr dran sind. Dann nehmen wir doch mal den Daniel ran. Hallo Daniel.
Ja, hallo.
Nein, gut, dass du noch da bist. Ich hatte schon Angst. Manchmal bin ich ja nicht so ganz koscher mit meinem Telefon hier und denke, dass mir das einen Streik spielt.
Also ich würde auch gerne ein bisschen was über diese Demokratiesache besprechen, was der mein Vorredner und der Erstredner gesagt hat, weil ich da ein bisschen anderer Meinung bin, weil ich glaube, dass die Möglichkeiten sich einzumischen ja da sind. Also das ist ja nicht irgendwie neu und so eine elektronische Sache kann eigentlich nur unterstützend wirken. Und also ich bin selber auch in der Partei jetzt recht frisch, aber seit letztem Jahr und habe gesagt, ich kann halt immer nicht immer nur große Sprüche klopfen, sondern muss mich auch selber mal ein bisschen engagieren. Und ich merke halt einfach wie wahnsinnig schwierig das ist. Wir sind hier in einem großen Bezirk in Treptow und sind vielleicht sieben Leute, die da was machen. Und wir haben natürlich auch unsere Internetseite und so weiter und die Reaktionen tendieren eher Richtung Null.
Liegt das vielleicht an der Internetseite?
Also ich sag mal, wir reden hier oder worüber die anderen Mitstreiter da vorhin gesprochen haben, das wäre eine wirklich direkte Demokratie, so wie in der Schweiz, auf dem Marktplatz, Schwert raus und kurz darüber abgestimmt. So funktioniert das ja in Deutschland nicht. Wir haben ja extra eine repräsentative Demokratie und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie das dann über das Internet funktionieren sollte an dem Punkt.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass eine repräsentative Demokratie, wir haben ja die Umfrage gehört, die wir heute auch die ganze Zeit in den Nachrichten zitieren, dass die repräsentative Demokratie mit ihren Vertretern so weit von der bürgerlichen Meinung abweicht, dass ein Großteil der Bevölkerung sagt, ich sehe nicht, dass das richtig ist, was sie da machen, und die haben die Leute schließlich gewählt.
Die Frage ist ja immer, warum weichen sie denn so ab? Neulich stand irgendwo in der Zeitung, wie viele Mitglieder in die Parteien in Deutschland haben, das waren so 1, 2 Millionen oder so. Wenn man jetzt mal die ganzen Karteileichen rausrechnet, machen wir einfach 50 Prozent raus, dann sind es 600.000. Und dann einfach mal durch Zweiteil ist die Regierungsmehrheit. Dann haben wir also praktisch in Deutschland 300.000 Leute, die 80 Millionen regieren, aktiv. Und da stellt sich mir die Frage, wer da der eigentliche Schuldige ist. Also hier sprach man immer von der Zivilgesellschaft, die keine Lobby hat und von dem Staat als abstrakten Ding, der da außen vor steht und macht was er will.
Das ist ja nicht so.
Im Endeffekt leiden ja die Parteien unter Mitgliederverlust. Und wir alle sind ja daran verdammt nochmal schuldig, da ein bisschen mitzumachen. Und wenn wir alle mehr tun würden, dann würde das auch über die elektronischen Wege viel, viel einfacher funktionieren. Dann müssten wir wahrscheinlich so eine Sendung heute Abend gar nicht wirklich diskutieren, weil das dann selbstverständlich ist. Denn es ist halt die Elektronik nur ein Medium, genau das zu produzieren, was wir alle tagtäglich im normalen Leben machen. Aber was macht denn jemand? Deshalb diskutieren wir darüber.
Aber glaubst du nicht, dass die Leute vielleicht auch ein bisschen resignieren? Also ich meine, da gab es schon so Geschichten, da stand zur Diskussion, dass der Oberste Gerichtshof seine Urteile im Volltext, so wie sie sind, eins zu eins online stellen sollte. Und dann gab es halt die Bedenken, naja, das kann man ja nicht machen, weil die könnten ja von den unbedarften Bürgern falsch interpretiert werden, sondern das müsste erstmal quasi durch eine, kommentiert werden von einem Verlag, was denn diese Gesetze herausbringt gegen Geld auch. Man hat also die Bedenken, dass irgendwie der Bürger das vielleicht falsch verstehen könnte, was da entschieden wurde und das dann zu Missverständnissen führt.
Ich glaube, die Frage, also warum sich vielleicht Staat und Regierung, warum sich Staat und Regierung von Bürgern mittlerweile so weit entfernt haben, ist, also wie jeder, der vielleicht schon mal in so einer politischen Partei rein geschnuppert hat, ist mehr oder minder gesagt eine Katastrophe, was da sich drum herumtummelt und die Mehrheit. Und wenn man sich das anguckt, ich bin jetzt 27 Jahre alt und ich bin nur eine wirklich kleine Partei, da ist nichts mit groß mit Jugend und repräsentativ ist das schon gar nicht, was sich da tummelt. Es sind teilweise Leute, die das zu ihrem Hobby machen oder es sind Leute, die da wirklich Karriere machen wollen. Die erkennt man auch sofort. Also die machen den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als das. Und die sind natürlich weit weg vom Bürger, aber der Bürger fehlt eigentlich in der Partei wirklich. Also einen richtigen Durchschnitt gibt es nicht. Also ich bin in einer kleinen Partei, das ist auch eine QNT-Partei, wenn man das fast so sagen darf, und da ist nichts repräsentativ.
Aber die Frage ist ja, woran liegt das? Weil deine Argumentation war ja wirklich relativ gut zu sagen, dass da diese Beteiligung fehlt. Und wenn du sagst, Zivilgesellschaft hat keine Lobby, und daran sei die Gesellschaft natürlich auch in einem gewissen Maße schuld dran, dass das so ist, weil sie sich selber nicht mehr dafür interessiert, da mitzumachen. Nur, wir haben natürlich auch eine Gesellschaft, die sich sehr an das Populäre gewöhnt hat. Das heißt, sie ist daran gewöhnt, das ProSieben-Sat.1 und auch die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, also Fernsehen, einem alles vorkauen, das alles schön kurz, es dauert nur zwei Minuten lang, das kann man alles so machen und man muss selber nichts mehr dabei tun. Nur, wo tun die Parteien denn was, das die Leute wirklich auch dazu bringen möchten, dann da mitzumachen bei so einer Partei, dass es ihnen gefällt? Die Möglichkeiten haben die Parteien doch in der Regel gar nicht.
Ja, das ist genau die Frage. Also wir selber haben ja auch unser erklägtes Internetforum aufgemacht und wir können halt nur so gewisse begrenzte Informationen natürlich da reinstellen. Und wenn man denn wirklich möchte und sich auch ein bisschen auskennt, das ist natürlich die Grundraufforaussetzung, dass man am Tag vielleicht mal eine Tageszeitung liest, dann kommt man eigentlich an die Information noch an. Und wenn es dann halt nicht weit genug geht, bin ich der Meinung, dann muss man auch einen sehr, sehr schwierigen Weg gehen. Und der schwierige Weg ist, sich in der Demokratie zu engagieren. Es kostet Zeit, es kostet auch Nerven und es ist auch manchmal sehr, sehr belastend. Aber ohne diesen Weg, funktioniert das halt nicht. Und die Vorstellung, die wir jetzt vielleicht heute Abend diskutieren, sich einfach abends an das Internet zu setzen und sagen, oh mein Gott, diskutieren wir heute mal über, weiß ich, die Vermögensteuer oder was, und dann klicken wir alle an und dann haben wir unsere Schuldigkeit getan. Das ist es doch eigentlich nicht, glaube ich.
Oder? Na ich denke, aber das ist es sicherlich nicht und das kann es wohl auch nicht sein, aber die Frage ist halt, wie hoch ist die Einstiegshürde, die du angesprochen hast, um tatsächlich mitmachen zu können, um sich rechtzeitig zu informieren? Aus welchen Medien kann ich mich denn informieren?
Die Einstiegshürde ist meiner Meinung nach recht niedrig. Also man kann sich gut informieren, wenn man Zeitungen liest, dann vielleicht ein, zwei oder drei, das kostet dich eine Stunde am Tag. Und dann schickt man halt, also ich bin halt einfach auch in die Partei eingetreten über eine E-Mail. Also ich hab halt einfach eine E-Mail geschrieben und wirklich innerhalb von zwei Tagen hatte ich Post. allen Informationsmaterialien.
Und dann war das schon mal zu dritt? Und dann war das schon mal zu dritt?
Was heißt zu dritt?
Achso, weil du gesagt hast, das ist eine kleine Partei.
Da weißt du ja als Scherz gemein.
Im Endeffekt kann man es aber wirklich nicht besorgen. Nee, aber das ging halt rucksrucks. Hab eine E-Mail geschrieben, hab eine Antwort bekommen. Und dann hatte ich die Post im Briefkasten. Und dann hatte ich auch alle Termine parat. Und konnte mir das das erste Mal angucken etc. Und konnte sagen, okay, das passt eher zu mir, das passt nicht. Hier kann ich vielleicht mitmachen, hier kann ich vielleicht was erreichen. Also die Hürde war recht niedrig. Das hat mich vielleicht eine halbe Stunde Zeit gekostet.
Aber wir haben alle gerade schon so ein bisschen die Nase gerümpft, als du meintest, dass die Einstiegshürde sehr niedrig sei, weil eine Tageszeitung am Tag oder zwei oder drei könne man ja innerhalb von einer Stunde so vertilgen. Du weißt schon, welche Zeitungen so der Bundesbürger im Schnitt morgens zur Hälfte genießt, dass es sich da glaube ich zu mehr als 50 Prozent um die Bildzeitung handelt und dass längere Texte, die irgendwie so eine Spaltenbreite von über 10 cm haben, da in der Regel gar nicht genommen werden, ne?
Das Problem sind meine Argumentationen sicherlich nicht so richtig standfast. Da gebe ich dir Recht.
Aber ich denke, wir gleiten so ein bisschen vom Thema auch ab. Also weil eigentlich wollten wir darüber reden, wie ist es, also was erwarten wir jetzt vom Staat? Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt was wissen will, konkret, wenn ich jetzt was Konkretes nachfragen will, welche Möglichkeiten habe ich da? Also es geht ja gar nicht darum, dieser Informationsfluss, der taktisch auf mich einrieselt, sondern es geht darum, wenn ich jetzt wirklich ein konkretes Problem habe oder was wissen will, was nachfragen will, wo kann ich die Informationen herbekommen? Wie kann ich jetzt sehen, welche Geldflüsse irgendwo sind oder welche Töpfe zum Beispiel sind? Kann ich jetzt irgendwie gucken, was in Neukölln mit dem Sozialamt ist, die weigern sich halt irgendwie Leuten Geld auszuzahlen, weil sie halt leere Kasse haben? Wo kann ich jetzt irgendwie gucken, ob sie wirklich kein Geld mehr haben, zum Beispiel wie viel schon ausgezahlt ist? Das ist keine Information, die jetzt wirklich geheim zu halten ist. Das will ich halt einfach nachgucken.
Ich studiere an der FATW, da ist ja seit zehn Jahren ein Problem des Umzugs. Und seit neun ist mal wieder so ein Gerücht am Laufen, dass die FATW wieder mal umziehen soll, noch schöne Weile etc. Aber niemand weiß wirklich, was genau ist. Das stand halt in der Zeitung. Und dann bin ich halt an unseren Abwehrordneten hier im Lokal herangetreten, hab gesagt, du kümmer dich mal drum. Und innerhalb kürzester Zeit hatte ich halt Informationen darüber, wie die Debatte im Senat halt abgelaufen ist. Die war schon öffentlich, aber da hat sich halt niemand drum gekümmert. Und damit weiß ich, dass die Entscheidung dort noch nicht gefallen ist. Und wie der Senat sich das vorstellt und wie die Gerüchte in der Universität rumrennen, die sind völlig unterschiedlich. Also die Möglichkeit, die die Wahrheit nicht unbedingt über das Internet gemacht hat.
War denn dieses Protokoll, ist das irgendwie öffentlich? Oder bist du da jetzt nur rangekommen, weil du da jetzt direkt an Abgeordneten gefragt hast?
Nö, der hat mir dann wiederum jemanden genannt, der der Hochschulpolitischer Sprecher einer Partei ist, mit dem habe ich dann telefoniert und habe ihn dann angesprochen und er hat mir dann den Stand genannt. Aber diese Sachen werden von den Parteien einzeln natürlich auch ein bisschen verarbeitet in ihrer Interessenlage, das darf man natürlich nicht vergessen, auch publiziert. Also das findet man auf den Internetseiten und wenn man dann sagt, okay, ich bin sehr neutral, dann lese ich mir halt das von der Partei durch, von der Partei und von der Partei und dann kann ich mir meiner Meinung nach schon eine Meinung bilden, weil eine richtig ungefilterte Information gibt es ja heutzutage eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das, was wir von den Behörden erwarten. Also quasi einen aktuellen Statusbericht, keine Interpretation durch irgendwelche Journalisten oder durch irgendwelche Politiker noch, die das irgendwie schönreden wollen und die im Interesse, sondern wir wollen dann wirklich wissen, wie da gerade der Stand ist.
Also ich sag mal, wenn es denn soweit ist, dass die Behörden dann berichten, dann ist das ja schon passiert, dann kann ich gerne keinen Einfluss mehr nehmen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie man Geldflüsse im Bezirksamt nachprüfen kann, etc. Das geht sicherlich auch über die Bezirksverordnetenversammlung. Das geht mit Sicherheit, weil die ja recht...
Hey, warum soll der Kontostand von Behörden nicht öffentlich sein? Gibt es da einen Grund für?
Boah, das ist eine schwierige Frage. Das ist eine wirklich schwierige Frage. Also vielleicht wär's mal ganz gut, wenn wir das öffentlich machen, damit jeder mal sieht, in welcher Lage wir uns eigentlich wirklich befinden.
Richtig.
Also da hätte ich auch gar nichts dagegen. Das ist ja auch nicht das Thema, womit ich von angefangen hab. Weil da ist ja Einmischung nicht mehr möglich, wenn ich mir den Kontostand abrufe.
Ja klar, aber das ist ja, denn die haben wenigstens alle Leute auch was ist. So, dann gibt's auch irgendwie keinen Gejammer, sondern können die Leute halt wirklich überlegen, okay, dann kann ich halt auch da irgendwie nichts mehr erwarten.
Keine extra Leistung. Ich glaube auch, dass das E-Government eigentlich nur eine Mitte zum Zweck sein kann. Also dass da noch mehr kommen muss von uns alle. Das haben wir ja auch gerade eben ein bisschen festgestellt. Und die Government kann eigentlich nur eine Unterstützung sein. Und solche transparenten Geschichten sind vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht, weil dann wir alle erstmal wirklich registrieren, dass es in unserem Staat wirklich knarrt bis ans Ende. Wir alle kriegen das irgendwie mit. Aber vielleicht halten wir uns auch noch ein bisschen die Augen zu und wollen die Transparenz auch gar nicht.
Ja, aber das ist ganz nett, weil wir uns ja jetzt wirklich über zehn Minuten so ein bisschen um das Thema drum rumgenährt haben. Also weil ein aktuelles Beispiel ist ganz schön daran zu sehen. Du hast gesagt, dass das okay ist und dass man sich gut informieren kann, wenn man Zeitung liest und aber auch gesagt, dass wenn diese Entscheidungen getroffen sind von den Abgeordneten, dass es dann schon zu spät ist. Wenn ich es in der Zeitung lese, ist es zu spät. Und das ist das Problem. Heute zum Beispiel kam es ganz groß in den Nachrichten in Berlin, der botanische Garten soll hier gekürzt werden. Alles was er so an Geld ankriegt, weil die FU da kürzen soll. Das haben alle, die im botanischen Garten angestellt sind, morgens über die Medien erfahren, dass Finanzsenator Sarrazin, da der FU gesagt hat, mach das doch mal so. Und die FU hat angefangen, das zu entscheiden. Wenn das Ganze eben über E-Government gelaufen wäre, über irgendeine Art und Weise, wo man sich beteiligen kann, dann hätte man vorher schon mal sagen können, nee, das kann doch so und so nicht gehen. Das kannst du eben nicht, wenn es in der Zeitung steht. Und da sind alle dran gewöhnt.
Also ich glaube dafür gibt es zwei Wege. Also ich könnte auch noch argumentieren, dass wenn jetzt mehr von den Leuten, die im Britanischen Garten arbeiten, sich vielleicht politisch engagiert hätten, hätten sie das vielleicht vorher mitbekommen. Und wenn man das halt auf zwei Wegen macht. Einmal über dieses E-Government, diese Information. Und zweitens die Leute natürlich aber auch in die Pflicht nehmen müssen und sagen, okay, das geht jetzt um uns, dann muss ich mich halt mal kümmern. Und der Weg ist schwierig, sich zu kümmern, also auf sich zu engagieren.
Das musst du den Leuten klar machen, Daniel. Das ist der Punkt. Du musst den Leuten nahebringen, dass es ihre Aufgabe ist. Und ich sehe nicht, dass das System momentan existiert, dass sowohl das politische System als auch die berühmte Macht tatsächlich aktiv Leute dafür belohnt, das zu kritisieren oder sie auch nur dazu aufruft.
Also ich glaube, da blicken wir genau an den richtigen Punkt. Dann komme ich nämlich zu der Frage, ob das überhaupt funktioniert, so wie du uns das vorstellst mit dem E-Government. Weil ich glaube, dass du zur Zeit, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, oder jemand von euch, dass es sehr unpopulär ist, Politik zu machen. Und dann ist es vielleicht auch nicht populärer, das über das Internet zu machen. Und wenn man sich selber engagiert und sagt, man ist in der Partei, man steht ja noch dazu, dann wird man wahrscheinlich eher naserümpfend angeguckt und gefragt, man kann ja eh nichts verändern. Aber man kann, also ein bisschen. Ich bin vielleicht schon ein bisschen idealistisch an dem Punkt. Aber ein bisschen, und ich möchte auch wirklich jeden auffordern, helft mit, weil da sind sehr, sehr viele Leute am Start, sag ich jetzt mal, die wirklich diese Forumpolitik benutzen, um sich nach oben zu schießen und die nicht wirklich der Sache dienen, sondern eher sich selbst. Und nur wir alle zusammen können das verhindern.
Vielleicht wirkt das ja bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt erstmal inspirierend. Heute Abend, Daniel, schön, dass du angerufen hast.
Vielen Dank, tschüss.
So, wir werden gleich Nachrichten machen hier im Chaos Radio, im Blue Moon, auf Fritz, wir haben es gleich halb zwölf, es wird natürlich auch gleich noch weitergehen, 031-77-91-110 ist die Nummer unter der ihr euch beteiligen könnt, wenn ihr möchtet am Chaos Radio heute Abend. Wir melden uns gleich mit den Nachrichten und ihr könnt gegebenenfalls schon mal überlegen, was ihr zum Thema elektronische Regierung sagen möchtet und dann anrufen hier bei Fritz.
Wenn Fritz über Satellit, dann Astra-Digital-Radio, Transponder 30.
23.31 Uhr.
Fritz, Info.
Mit dem Wetter in den Abplatz hocken bei Kiespferden zwischen 6 und 2 Grad. Morgen wird es genauso schön wie heute. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 17 bis 20 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkov.
In Berlin und Köln hat es eine tödliche Schießerei gegeben. Da wurde ein Polizist, tötet ein weiterer, wurde sehr verletzt. Die Polizisten wollten in einer Wohnung einen Mann verhaften, wegen dem wegen einer Messerstöcherei ein Haftbefehl vorliegt. Die drei großen Berliner Unis planen einen totalen Zulassungs- und Einstellungsjob. Sie reagierten damit auf neue Sparpläne von Finanzsenator Zara Zin. Die Humboldt-Uni will schon im kommenden Wintersemester keine Studenten aufnehmen und ab sofort keine Stellen neu besetzen, heißt es. Im Irak ist eine neue Widerstandsgruppe gegründet worden. Sie nennt sich Irakische Nationale Befreiungsorganisation. Die Gruppe hat den bewaffneten Kampf gegen die Alliierten angekündigt. Abtreibungen dürfen als Mord oder als neuer Holocaust bezeichnet werden. Das hat das Oberlandesgericht Karlsruhe entschieden. Es gab ein Mannrecht, der mehrmals vor einer Abtreibungsklinik in Heidelberg demonstriert hatte. Der Blick auf die Straßen der Verkehr rollt und wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Was haben Cottbus und Berlin im Juni gemeinsam?
Falsch, Nelkenhass?
Auch falsch.
Rosenstolz?
Richtig!
Komm ich jetzt im Fernsehen?
Nein. Nein.
Und im Radio? Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Berlin und Brandenburg. Es handelt sich tatsächlich wirklich um die Nummer 1 der Teilen ins Schneemparade, ist das richtig? Das ist korrekt, richtig. Ja, dann müssen wir ganz kurz indisponieren. Eine Sekunde. Herrliches Equipment. Bin sehr gespannt. Schon mal gesagt haben, nimmt das Thema E-Government.
Und E-Government wollen wir heute versuchen, auch mit eurer Hilfe so ein bisschen einzukreisen und ein bisschen zu definieren, was das eigentlich ist. Wir haben das mal versucht, als das Verhältnis zwischen Bürger und Staat auf elektronische Medien abwickeln, sowohl in der Form der Beteiligung, als auch der Dienstleistungen seitens des Staats gegenüber dem Bürger, als auch natürlich die Dokumentation der Arbeit der Regierung, also eine Transparenz der Regierung hin zum Bürger. Da hatten wir einige Anrufe bisher zum Beispiel zum Thema E-Learning zu Beteiligungen in Bundestagssitzungen, zur Abwicklung von Diensten wie Meldewesen, Steuer und ähnlichen Dingen. Oder eben auch die stärkeren Möglichkeiten, sich einzubringen, ob die nun erwachsen oder nicht. Das ist ja nur ein zusätzlicher Weg zur existierenden Struktur. Und da möchten wir gerne mit euch darüber sprechen unter der 0331 70 97 110.
Da ist doch was hängen geblieben. Thema zusammengefasst hat gerade noch mal der Andreas vom Chaos Computer Club. Auch noch da der Frank im Studio und meine Person Max Formalocki. Heute Abend, euch hätten wir gerne am Telefon zu dem Thema und zu der Nummer. Die habt ihr ja gerade gehört, 0331 77 97 110. Habt ihr alle in euer Telefon, wenn ihr zum Thema elektronische Beteiligung, elektronische Möglichkeiten in diesem Gebiet, E-Government, was beitragen möchtet. Wie zum Beispiel der Enrico Ostfeld. Bei dir besteht eine Besonderheit, das kann man ruhig dazu sagen. Du bist nämlich Kreistagsabgeordneter. Was ist denn deine Meinung zu dem Thema? Würdest du denn überhaupt mit der Masse der Menschen Kontakt auf elektronischem Wege aufnehmen wollen?
Ja natürlich und das tue ich eigentlich im Moment auch schon. Ich denke einfach mal, die Möglichkeiten, die sich jetzt schon bieten, wie die Vorurine der Parteien, ja die Möglichkeit Einwohnerfragestunden wahrzunehmen und ähnliche, die werden einfach noch viel zu wenig genutzt. Und natürlich kämpfe ich auch bei uns so ein bisschen mit dafür, dass diese elektronischen Sachen sehr viel mehr Raum bekommen. Aber man kann schwer, ja gerade auch ältere Leute von überzeugen, diese Medien noch zu akzeptieren, wenn man nicht wenigstens Bedarf nachweisen kann. Und wenn dann Eingefahren nicht groß genutzt wird, ist das immer ein bisschen schwierig.
Heißt das im Umkehrschluss, dass ganz viele junge Leute das schon nutzen?
Es gibt viele, die das schon nutzen, ja.
Was macht denn jeder so? Nur mal so als Beispiel, der Feltener, was hat er so angeboten bekommen, wo er sich beteiligen kann? Und was für Fragen oder was für Anfragen kommen da so rein auf elektronischem Weg?
Ja, Anfragen kommen noch relativ wenig an, aber das betrifft natürlich immer Haftthemen. Also in letzter Zeit eher so der Punkt-Mill-Verbrauchsanlage und solche Sachen waren bei uns ziemlich akut. Angebote sind da, zum Beispiel gibt es eine bisher völlig ungenutzte Aktion, die Feltener Tafeln, ein elektronisches Forum, was sich mit der Zukunft der Stadt beschäftigt. Denn bietet natürlich, auch meine Partei, ich will sie jetzt nicht nennen, ist ja kein Wahlkampf hier, bietet auch Folien, in denen speziell auch zur Jugendpolitik und zu vielen anderen Themen gesprochen werden kann. Aktuelle Beschlüsse oder wichtige Themen wie Schulentwicklung und Ähnliches sind auf der Seite des Landkreises mit Dokumenten unterfüttet, also Schulentwicklungsteilnahmen runtergeladen werden und kann dann zur Diskussion dienen. Nicht so gut finde ich das dann auf Landes- oder Bundesebene, wo die Probleme meist ziemlich komplex sind, weil das dann direkte Mitdruckung sicherlich schwer realisierbar ist. Schon im Prozess der Meinungsbildung, da muss man ansetzen und nicht bei Themen, die gerade akut in der Politik da sind, weil da sind dann meistens alle Menschen schon gewöhnt.
Aber man kann jetzt natürlich nicht von Schuld voll gerade sprechen, aber wem gibt es denn, also nicht Schuld, aber sagen wir mal, wem würdest du da die Schuld geben, woran hängt, dass da nicht so viel Beteiligung stattfindet? Sind es nur die Leute, sind die zu faul, haben die keine Ahnung, was die machen sollen, macht ihr zu wenig Werbung dafür oder könnt das selber nicht vermitteln, woran liegt?
Also es liegt sicherlich daran, dass gerade die Leute, die diese Angebote schaffen, selber nicht unbedingt die Computer-Frequenz oder nicht unbedingt sich in dem Rahmen bewegen und das da natürlich schwer ist, das Angebot so abzustimmen, dass es auch angenommen wird. Und vor allem gerade für Politik schon immer schwer, gerade auch in den letzten Jahren, die Leute auf die Leute zu drehen oder die Leute auch zu finden. Oder ein Abgeordneter kann nicht an allen Orten gleichzeitig sein und überall für seine Position werden. Daher fehlen einfach diese gemeinsamen Schnittpunkte, wie er schon sagte, zwischen Zivilgesellschaft und den Abgeordneten. Das ist bei uns auf Kreiseeben noch nicht ganz so gravierend, aber auf Bundesebene ist das natürlich noch kritischer. Aber es wird viel versucht, aber man findet Seiten zusammen. Ich steck mal beide Seiten.
Und gab es ein Projekt, nur dass man mal so vielleicht auch so einen positiven kleinen Aufglüher hat, wo ihr sagt, da hat es ungewöhnlich gut funktioniert an der Stelle, dass da mal sowas genutzt wurde auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise?
Ich denke mal, das ist kein erster Projekt, aber gerade die Online-Foren hier von Politik Digital, das sind schon ein bisschen und die wird auch von vielen Leuten gelesen, die Entscheidungen damit beeinflussen. Das ist nicht so, dass diese Foren, wo sonst eigentlich eher Menschen sich untereinander unterhalten oder Bürger sich untereinander halten, also ich weiß, dass da viele auch von uns bei sind, die dort einfach mitdiskutieren, aber das nicht immer den Amt und Hürden, sagen wir so.
Das ist aber auch ganz interessant, das mal zu wissen, dass ihr da auch einen Blick rein werft und dass das nicht immer so als die Outsider-Kiste gewertet wird.
Nein, nun können wir es sehen. Ja, für mich der zweite Punkt, der vielleicht noch wichtig ist, dass das Delaware-E-Government ist. Da würde ich schon sagen, da wird in den nächsten Jahren sich eine Menge entwickeln, wenn diese Projekte um die digitalen Signaturen und so weiter endlich so fortgeschritten sind, dass der Gesetzgeber das auch hundertprozentig anerkennen kann. Und wird hoffentlich. Ich kann nur von uns aus dem Landkreis berichten, wir arbeiten an vielen Projekten. Das fängt damit an, dass biografische Systeme für Bauanträge usw. dass das alles verfasst wurde, dass wir alle möglichen Anträge, die an Landkreise oder Städte oder so weiter herangetragen werden, normalerweise elektronisch dargestellt werden können. Das Problem ist dann natürlich aber auch, dass das nicht so sein soll, im Endeffekt, dass man das elektronisch kriegt und hinterher in die altbewährten Programme eintippt, sondern gerade der Aufwand ist da, die Schnittstellen zu schaffen zwischen der Internetphase und dem selbst genutzten Programm. Und da gibt es dann leider auch viele Gesetze, die verhindern, dass da Open Source und so weiter angewendet werden dürfen. Man denkt gerade im Jugendbereich, da sind viele Sicherheitsfragen, spielen da eine Rolle auch. Und solange da nicht eine vernünftige, wirklich sichere Methode da ist, ist das immer sehr schwierig. Vorschriften, welche Programme ein Amt wofür einsetzen darf. Die müssen zertifiziert sein und solche Sachen. Und die bieten dann natürlich, wie man das erkennt, von Softwarefirmen nicht die Schnittstellen, weil man natürlich das eigene Produkt hier da sichern möchte.
Aber ich als Lyle kann mir da drunter jetzt nicht wirklich was vorstellen. Heißt das, du darfst irgendwie Word oder eine Powerpoint-Präsentation für sowas nicht verwenden? Oder was bedeutet das?
Ja doch, gerade das. Das Problem ist, du musst dich verwenden.
Also diese normale Office-Software kann ich verwenden. Aber wenn ich dann das in die Fachprogramme, wenn ich die Daten dann noch übernehmen möchte, da sperrt sich dann das Programm im Normalfall gegen. Die bietet also nicht die Schnittstein nach außen, die ich nutzen kann, um andere Programme rein mit einzubinden oder eine Internetplattform mit einzubinden oder ähnliches. Das heißt, der Sachbearbeiter im Amt müsste sein altes Programm nehmen und müsste das, was das Online-Ernahmungsfach reinigt, richtet, hier abschreien.
Das komplizierte daran.
Ja, das ist nicht wirklich ein...
Die Entwicklung solcher Programme oder gerade auch im Open-Soft-Bereich wird da natürlich verhindert, da die Software-Minen auf ihrem Programm dann natürlich zucken und das Schnittständer außen nicht so gerne sehen.
Wobei das aber heißt, die technische Umsetzung ist schon in Arbeit, möchte ich richtig verstehen.
Ja, natürlich.
Es gibt aber Probleme, die dominierenden Hersteller, die so einen gewissen, sag ich mal, Wirtschaftsprotektionismus genießen, was ja auch mit diesem Rahmenvertrag zwischen Herrn Schily und Microsoft künftig wieder zementiert wurde. Und das auch akut tatsächlich den Einsatz von Open Source Helmet. Hast du das richtig verstanden?
Das Helmet, ja. Das wird in viele Richtungen gearbeitet. So langsam bräuchert da die Front auch. Aber das ist natürlich immer noch schwierig.
Also ich hab mal ein bisschen zur Vorbereitung hier auf die Sendung so rumgeklickt, was es so an Produkten und an Systemen gibt für E-Government oder elektronische Verwaltung mehr. Das ist eine ganze Menge. Also da tut sich was. Allerdings sind das dann oft auch geschlossene Sachen. Also ich konnte auch nirgendswo reingucken, wie denn jetzt so ein Protokoll aussieht, wie irgendwie ein Datensatz zum Beispiel, wie ein Händler automatisch elektronisch beim Kraftfahrzeug ein Fahrzeug anmelden kann. Dafür gibt es ein Softwarepaket, dafür gibt es irgendwie definierte Schnittstellen, aber es ist natürlich irgendwie nicht rauszukriegen, wie die funktionieren oder wie das irgendwie vor sich geht. Oder zum Beispiel wenn jetzt eine Meldbehörde, wenn ich da jetzt einen Reisepass beantrage, dann gibt es jetzt schon Systeme, wo dann irgendwie ein Scanner steht, wo irgendwie das Foto eingescant wird, der Antrag, irgendwie alles elektronisch an die Bundesdruckerei übermittelt wird. Dann gibt es verschiedene Softwareanbieter. Nur ist das natürlich auch alles nicht wirklich transparent und auch schon gar nicht offen für andere Hersteller, so zunächst.
Also mit eins der Probleme. Und wenn dann natürlich eine Kreuzverwaltung oder eine Stadtverwaltung viel Geld irgendwann mal ausgegeben hat, was führt diese Programme und diese damit verbundenen Verträge, das wird natürlich auch schwer vermittelbar, warum da jetzt irgendein anderes Projekt angegangen wäre, wenn da die Daten konvertiert werden müssen und solche Sachen.
Klar, das ist dann der Moloch, der bewegt werden muss.
Das Geld ist natürlich immer noch der Haupthintergrund dabei.
Enrico, vielen Dank für diesen Einblick in das, was wir wahrscheinlich sonst nie erfahren hätten, weil man da nicht hintersteckt und weil man es wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht wissen will, wenn man es nicht erzählt bekommt, Enrico. Das ist ein netter Service gewesen an dieser Stelle.
Einen Bitt hab ich noch, wenn ihr den Termin für morgen dort nochmal bekannt geben sollt, wäre ich sehr zufällig.
Machen wir gleich nochmal.
Danke schön.
Das können wir eigentlich nochmal machen, denn zum einen könnt ihr euch natürlich über Telefon unter 033 77 97 110 hier an der Sendung beteiligen. Chaosradio auf Fritz am heutigen Abend. Wenn ihr grundsätzlich zum Thema was sagen möchtet, was nicht heute Abend zur Sprache kommt, aber per Mail dann in den folgenden Tagen auch für euch beantwortet werden könnte, dann schickt eine Mail an 81 als zahle, die Achtung, die eins, at chaosradio.ccc.de oder ihr bewegt euch morgen körperlich.
Und zwar in Marienstraße 11 nach Mitte in die Räume von Berliner CCC. Das ist ein Hinterhaus, kostet keinen Eintritt und geht los so um 20 Uhr. Und da wollen wir das Ganze, was wir jetzt hier noch mit euch besprechen, da in eine gemütliche Runde weiterführen.
Ist das denn was so ein Schild dran ist, oder ist das wieder so eine dunkle Heckerbutze, wo ich mich nicht reintraue?
Dunkle Heckerbutze. Nee, es ist draußen zu erkennen, da steht gerade ein ganz fürchterliches Baugerüst vor, was in seinem schönen Chaosknoten, der blau leuchtet, nachts, verdeckt. Und dann ist es irgendwie durch so eine Baustellensituation. Es ist ein bisschen blöd, aber hinten ist es irgendwie ganz nert und gemütlich.
Jo, dann, achso, was ich euch noch fragen wollte, weil das gerade noch kurz zur Sprache kam, was ist das für eine Handvertrag mit Microsoft? Weil ich hab irgendwie in letzter Zeit, ich dachte der Kollege, der Kollege Schili, war mir das jetzt noch mal aufgefallen, dass er, da ging es glaube ich um PGP oder PGPI, dass PGPI eingestellt werden sollte, weil der Hersteller es nicht mehr supportet, blablabla. Und dann hat der Herr Schili initiiert, dass man so etwas wie GNU-PGP macht, was eine Open Source-basierende Geschichte gewesen sein soll.
Ganz tolle Software, hast du die mal probiert?
Ja, die war kacke, aber dann war PDP ja auch auf einen gerettet und von einer anderen Firma aufgekauft und es gab das Problem nicht mehr. Aber das sah mir eher so aus, als würde der in Richtung Open Source gehen und sich des Problems bewusst sein und nicht unbedingt mit einem Hersteller wie Microsoft eine bestimmte Sache anfangen.
Allerdings ist es natürlich einfach mal ein Problem. Eine ganze Verwaltung komplett, da sind irgendwie 100.000 Leute, die da mit irgendwie jeden Tag arbeiten, mit so Microsoft Word und denen es mal irgendwie unter der Nase wegzuziehen, sagen ihr müsst jetzt was anderes benutzen, ist natürlich auch schon ein harter Schritt und naja.
Dann lieber den Feind umarmen anstatt ihm aus dem Weg zu gehen oder was?
Die Frage ist halt, was für Optionen er gehabt hat. Also ich sehe das schon als kritische Abwägung, die der Mann treffen musste. Der momentan bestehende Rahmenvertrag zwischen Microsoft und der Bundesregierung läuft noch bis 2004, läuft dann aus.
Was sieht er vor, was ist das für ein Vertrag?
Das ist ein Vertrag über den Bezug von Software zu bestimmten Konditionen für nachgeordnete Einrichtungen auf Landesebene, auf Kommunal-Ebene etc. Um eben verbindende Schnittstellen schon mal zu haben zwischen den einzelnen Einrichtungen. Zu den immer wieder betonten Zielen von Schilis IT-Politik gehört aber auch eine Heterogenisierung dieser IT-Infrastruktur in der öffentlichen Verwaltung, um Abhängigkeiten gegenüber z.B. Unternehmen wie Microsoft zu verringern. Dazu gehört auch Linux, dazu gibt es einen Support-Rahmenvertrag mit IBM. Allerdings muss man natürlich sicherstellen, dass in dieser Übergangsphase Microsoft Software und Updates und Support noch verfügbar sind. Hier geht es hauptsächlich um Support. Dazu hat er einen neuen Rahmenvertrag abgeschrieben. Die negative Seite des Ganzen ist natürlich, dass er damit auch für die nächsten 3 oder 4 Jahre schon mehr oder weniger die informationstechnische Ausgestattung der meisten, vielleicht so 90-95% der deutschen Verwaltungen, festschreibt.
Und das Geld auch schon ausgegeben hat.
Über das sie übrigens Stichschweigen bewahrt haben, in welcher Höhe die Abschlagszahlungen passieren.
Wo wir wieder bei dem Punkt wären, ob man das nicht einfach mal irgendwo abrufbar haben sollte, elektronisch wie viel Geld wofür eigentlich ausgegeben wird. Im Endeffekt ist es ja unser Geld, das ist ja das lustige an der Sache. Ich wollte noch mal wissen zur Hintergrundinformation, weil das ist immer so ein Schlagwort und dann weiß man nämlich nicht, was der Herr Schiedi dann in Wirklichkeit gemacht hat. Und das weiß man dann auch wieder nur zur Hälfte. Am Telefon ist die Judith. Hallo Judith, bist du noch dran?
Ja, klar.
Weil wir hatten vorhin das Stichwort Jugendforum und da hast du dann wahrscheinlich direkt gedacht, ach, da rufe ich doch mal an, du bist aus Köpenick und machst was im Jugendforum, wenn wir das richtig verstehen?
Ja, genau, ich sitze da so rum, nein, und wir besprechen da Probleme und so, also wie schon genannt.
Was macht ihr denn da? Erzähl mal ein bisschen, was das Jugendforum ist, weil es ist jetzt auch schon wieder 20 Minuten her, was ihr da macht und was das Jugendforum will und was ihr da wollt.
Na ja, so ein Gremium aus verschiedenen Jugendeinrichtungen, also da kommen dann immer Vertreter von diesen Jugendeinrichtungen hin und auch Erwachsene kommen dazu und das wird alles protokolliert und so mit Partei und dann kann man richtig Probleme besprechen. Also am Anfang wusste ich gar nicht, dass es so ernst ist und auch so bekannt ist, aber jetzt kriege ich das so langsam mit und ja, doch es ist ziemlich ernst und werden auch gut wichtige Probleme besprochen.
Ist es denn dann, was die Umsetzung anbelangt, mehr als Spielerei, also nach dem Motto, ja, wir reden mal mit den Jugendlichen und dann machen wir halt unseren Job, wenn wir dann abends nach Hause gehen und haben den halben Tag vergeudet oder lassen die sich tatsächlich beeinflussen, die Leute mit denen ihr dann in Kontakt kommt?
Ja, also das hab ich auch erst so, am Anfang musste ich ein bisschen schmunzeln, dachte ich, naja, das wird ja eh nichts so mit der Umsetzung, aber die haben so richtig versprochen, dass natürlich nicht große, also da wird nicht großes, dicke Geld verteilt, aber dass man so kleine Probleme, die man sozusagen sich selbst, also selbst lösen kann, versucht, Lösungen dafür zu finden, also wie man sich sozusagen selbst helfen kann. Weil viele Jugendanrichtungen haben auch die Möglichkeit, sich selbst zu helfen, aber es wird nicht erlaubt, auf rechtlichen Sinne oder was weiß ich.
Hast du da mal ein Beispiel, weil das ja sehr abstrakt ist?
Bei irgendeiner Jugendanrichtung, die haben zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Einrichtungen, die die an Jugendliche oder auch an Erwartungen vermieden könnten. Und dafür können sie Geld einnehmen. Und das können sie sozusagen zum Aufbau dieser Jugendanrichtung benutzen. Aber das wird ihnen irgendwie verwehrt und dadurch geht die Jugendanrichtung die Brach runter.
Also so Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe so ein bisschen auch. Und was habt ihr sonst so besprochen? Ist das dann in der Regel so diese kommunale Ebene auch? Oder geht es da auch um Probleme, die die Bundesrepublik so im Großen betreffen?
Naja, eigentlich ist es mehr so regional, also Berlin. Und deshalb gibt es nur die Vertreter Berliner Jugendanrichtung. Aber ich denke, das ist für Jugendliche auf Bundesebene wichtig, dass man schon besprechen kann und dass es alles ordentlich in Gang geht. Und dass man auch was zu sagen hat, wo man ja noch in diesem Alter nicht wählen kann und auch nicht so wirklich das Mitspracherecht hat. Es ist schon wichtig, dass man sich irgendwo melden kann und mal sagen kann, wir wollen das aber nicht so haben.
Und wie gut, glaubst du, ist es realisiert?
Keine Ahnung, wir hatten erst eine Sitzung. Und ich hoffe, dass man sich richtig einsetzen kann für sein Problem. Aber es ist schon sehr gut organisiert, also richtig mit Protokollieren, mit Tonbeamt und allen möglichen Leuten, die da aus Parteien mithelfen, dass das gut umgesetzt wird und so.
Wo gehst du da genau hin und wo findet das statt?
Du bist jetzt aus Köpenick?
Ja, also das ist im Rathaus Treptow. Aber die sind sich immer mit den Örtlichkeiten nicht so einig. Also vielleicht findet es das nächste Mal woanders statt. Aber dieses Mal, das erste Mal, hat es im Rathaus Treptow stattgefunden.
www.jugend-forum.de war die Adresse, wo man da Infos zu finden kann.
Ja, ich wollte auch noch mit dem Internet sagen, dass es sehr wichtig ist für Jugendliche in unserem Alter und auch überhaupt Jugendliche, wichtig ist es sich über das Internet informieren zu können und auch sich austauschen zu können. Also nicht nur über Chat oder so, aber dass es wichtig ist, dass man auch solide Informationen bekommt. Nicht nur so, du gehst auf eine Seite und dann kommt dann irgendwie, ja diese Seite ist leider nicht aufbereit. Ich weiß jetzt nicht woran das liegt, aber irgendwie, ich habe so viele Seiten, die mir gute Informationen, die mir versprochen haben, als ich angeklickt habe, dass dann plötzlich kam, ja verschlüsselte Seite oder das geht nicht. Und ich finde, es müsste irgendwie besser geprüft werden, dass es auch wirklich dann funktioniert, wenn man diese Informationen haben will.
Also, Entschuldigung, aber sag mal als Schülerin hast du zum Beispiel auch mal das Interesse, zum Beispiel in deine Schülerakte mal rein zu gucken. Also das wäre ja so eine Sache, die vergleichbar ist. Wenn ich jetzt als Erwachsener wie auch immer sage, ich will jetzt bei den Behörden in meine Akten rein gucken, habe ich ja als Schüler parallel dazu auch zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, in meine Schülerakte rein zu gucken. Was denn so über mich gespeichert wird, oder so eine Sache, was da jetzt über mich notiert wird, oder so, würdest du das auch wahrnehmen wollen?
Doch, eigentlich schon. Ich wusste gar nichts davon, also dass man das machen kann. Aber ich würde das schon gerne, oder dass man das machen würde können, oder was weiß ich. Aber ich finde das schon eigentlich ganz interessant, mal zu sehen, was die einem da so rein schreiben und ob es auch wirklich alles mit rechtem Sinn zugeht und so.
Es gibt Fristen dafür, so weit ich weiß. Also zum Beispiel auch für die Arbeiten, die man, also es war glaube ich in Düsseldorf so, die Arbeiten, die man am Abitur schreibt, kann man erst noch eine bestimmte Anzahl von Jahren einsehen, die Korrekturen.
So weit ich weiß, wahrscheinlich bis irgendwelche Ansprüche verjährt sind.
Genau, ja klar, die Lagerfristen. Richtig, ja klar, richtig.
Damit du nicht sagen kannst, dagegen möchte ich aber Einspruch einlegen. Genau deswegen gibt es diese Fristen. Judith, nur mal so vom Altersschnitt her. Du bist jetzt 14, klingst sehr engagiert und interessiert. Was ist denn so der Altersschnitt von den Leuten, die du in diesem Forum kennengelernt hast? Sind das nicht nur 31-jährige pfeifenrauchende Typen, die in diesem Jugendforum sonst neben dir sitzen?
Ne, genau das ist das Gute, dass wir, also auch Vertreter dieser Jugendentrichtung, eigentlich alle in unserem Alter sind sozusagen, für die die Einrichtung eigentlich geschaffen sind. Also dass wir, die eigentlich diese Einrichtung nutzen wollen, dass wir da auch Mitspracherecht haben und dass wir dann sozusagen uns für unsere eigenen Interessen einsetzen können. Also wir sind eigentlich alle so im Jugendlichen Alter, so 16, aufwärts, abwärts, so. Also doch, da sind schon Erwachsene dabei, aber die halten sich eigentlich im Hintergrund und beantworten eigentlich hauptsächlich nur Fragen.
Gut, dann bleibt eigentlich abschließend nur zu sagen, dass man bei der Internetadresse mal vorbeisurfen kann, wenn man sich dafür auch interessiert. www-jugendforum.de Jugendminus?
Wir schicken's.
Genau. 81etausradio.cct.de Jugendminus Forum.de war die Adresse. Judith, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Und ein Song für Marie.
Das hast du ja schnell angesagt. Ich dachte, du machst jetzt einen Bohai. Es kommt also St. Andreas und Frank Befürworter, das wird natürlich auch ein Song für Marie. Andreas mit einem glänzenden Augen, Frank Feinfast auf der linken Seite des Studios hier bei Fritz. Wir haben es 0 Uhr, ihr hört das Chaosradio. Man möchte es kaum glauben, aber das war jetzt mal einfach mal die romantische Seite eines Themas wie E-Government dargestellt in Musik. Jungs lacht nicht, sonst kommt das nicht authentisch.
Ich bin ein bisschen schuld.
Die drei Musikerinnen im Studio, wie gesagt Andreas, Frank und Max mit dem Thema E-Government, elektronische Regierung. Vielleicht, Andreas, du hast es vorhin so schön zusammengefasst, kannst du noch mal so die letzten Äußerungen, die wir hatten, kurz anreißen, damit alle, die gerade erst schritz eingestaltet haben, so ein bisschen wissen, worüber in den ersten zwei Stunden schon diskutiert worden ist. Und dann haben wir das Thema ja auch direkt wieder ein bisschen umrissen.
Wir haben uns ein bisschen darüber unterhalten, welche Services denn der Staat seinen Bürgern zur Verfügung stellt, welche Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten der Bürger in der Demokratie hat und inwiefern E-Government als zusätzliche Möglichkeit neben den bestehenden Strukturen es vielleicht erleichtert und die Hemmschwelle hinwegnimmt, um sich zu beteiligen.
Am Telefon unter 031 70 97 110 angerufen hat der Robert aus Hamburg. Du bist aber laut. Hab ich mich jetzt gerade ein bisschen verschätzt hier mit meinem kleinen Regler. Wir haben ja gerade eben darüber gesprochen mit dem Kollegen, der als Kreisabgeordneter arbeitet, über Software und wie das Ganze eingekauft wird und was für Beschränkungen es da so gibt und was für Möglichkeiten man hat. Du bist offensichtlich jemand, der bei so einem Elektronikkonzern das ganze, solche Sachen auch programmiert und herstellt, oder?
Ich bin bei einer Hamburger Firma, die sich halt mit dem Bereich Elektronik-Government beschäftigt. Wir sind halt für öffentliche Auftraggeber, für Kommunen und öffentliche Banken und Versicherungen zuständig und betreuen die. Und ich muss halt erstmal sagen, dass die Städte eigentlich ganz gut ausgestattet sind. Auf meiner Sicht also sicherlich noch viel Verbesserungsbedarf, aber sehr, sehr viele Kommunen haben zumindest irgendwie eine e-Mail-Adresse und wenn es irgendwie ein Account ist bei T-Online, dann muss ich sagen, dass halt auch Elektronik-Government gleichbedeutend ist mit einer Verwaltungsmodernisierung. Also die Verwaltung auch in so einer IT-Selbe zu führen und die bis dort auszubauen. Da geht es dann auch um Dokumentenmanagement und wie der Kommunalpolitiker davor schon gesagt hat, dass wir auch Kreizeitsabgeordnete um Bauantragsverfahren, die offengelegt werden. Und mit dieser Verwaltungsmodernisierung wird natürlich auch eine Bürgernähe geschaffen. Und gewisse Sachen sind ja heute auch schon möglich. Also wie gesagt, wir sind im Bereich, also ich verantworte mit dem Bereich Wissungsdienst. Das heißt, der Bürger kann in öffentliche Wissungen von den Kommunalpolitikern reingucken und kann im Internet sich dann angucken, was haben diese auf der Tagesordnung gehabt und was sind da für Beschlüsse gefallen. Welche Fraktion hat denn das gesagt, dass jetzt der Bürger steigend besser wird oder auch nicht?
Und sicher jetzt schon an die Zukunftsmusik, die überall umgesetzt ist, habt ihr das schon also auf weiter Fläche verkauft oder ist das jetzt irgendwo schon mal in einer oder an der anderen Kommune?
In 200 Kommunen draußen, also 200 Kunden haben wir, also 200 Kommunen, 200 öffentliche Einrichtungen. Und ich würde mal sagen, ja, 120 setzen da unser Produkt ein. Also da gibt es ein Basismodul, eine Windows-Anwendung, wo halt die Systeme plant werden und die Dokumente erstellt werden können, automatisch mit Word. Und da gibt es halt ein Internetmodul, das ist auch für Linux verfügbar. Das ist AFP-Programmierung, aber läuft in der Linux durch so eine Chili-Soft-Emulation von FUN. Und es ist eigentlich so, wie ich eben gesagt habe, man geht dort in den Sitzungskalender, sieht die Sitzung und sieht da der Bauschuss, tagt am 14. dann gehe ich da rein und sehe natürlich die öffentlichen Punkte. Und das ist auch eine sichere Sache dahingehend, dass beide Sensationen zwischen dem Server im Rathaus und dem beim Provider, wenn das nicht selbst gehorcht wird, eigentlich nur die Dokumente übertragen werden, die unkritisch sind, die öffentlich sind, die jeder einsehen kann und nicht öffentliche werden halt nicht übertragen. Da gibt es den besonderen Bereich hier nochmal für den Kommunalpolitiker, für den Bürger und für das Rathaus, für das Internet.
Aber warum ist das so? Die Trennung.
Die Trennung. Weil einmal die Zielrichtung ist, diese Informationen anders aufzubereiten. Also einmal für den Bürger, da kann er nicht alle Informationen einsehen. Also wenn es beim Personalangelegenheit zum Beispiel im Rathaus geht, dann schien die, die sich nur im Rathaus drehen, oder einfach auch, dass die Fraktion, beispielsweise die SPD-Fraktion, bereitet was vor und dann darf die CDU natürlich da nicht im Vornherein reingucken. Das sind einfach so, ja, wie sie sagen sollen, und natürlich die unterschiedlichen Interessenlager der Zielgruppe, Kommunalpolitiker, Verwaltungsangestellter und Bürger. Und ich würde ganz genau ein paar Sachen von meinen Stichpunkten, die ich mir so ein bisschen schnell gemacht habe, ansprechen.
Ganz kurze Frage noch, Zwischenfrage. Da ihr ja auch sicherlich Support bietet und euch weiterhin um euer System kümmern, wenn das mal eingerichtet ist, wisst ihr denn noch so ein bisschen was über Userverhalten und wie viele Leute das denn auch in Anspruch nehmen, abgesehen davon, dass ihr den Service jetzt anbietet?
Ja, also wir haben, also die Städte schalten halt das Bürgerinfo nach außen. Und da muss man sagen, am besten ist es, wenn es begleitet wird, mit jemandem bekannt zu machen, dass es halt möglich ist, dass die Leute richtig schöne Sachen auf ihrer Webseite stellen und dem Bürger nicht Bescheid sagen. Und der sich dann halt selber suchen muss und es ist so eine dritte Menüstruktur hinten rechts und keiner findet das, außer dem Eingesalten. Und die Zielgruppe ist jetzt auch hauptsächlich zur Zeit noch der Kommunalpolitiker und der Sachbearbeiter intern, vor allem der Kommunalpolitiker, der sich über das Internet von zu Hause auf so eine Sitzung vorbereiten kann. Aber der Bürger hat eine Vielzahl an Informationen. Es gibt jetzt die Verwaltungen, die da bzw. die Städte, die da Statistiken fahren. Und, was soll ich da sagen, es kommt auf die Größe der Kommune an, auf die Größe der Stadt. Aber sehr glücklich, wie viele Leute da pro Woche sind. Aber es gibt Leute, die, wenn sie es erkannt haben, sich da schon informieren, speziell so um ihre Geschichten, wenn sie halt hingegangen sind und halt ihre Laternen in der Straße kaputt und sie gehen zur Verwaltung, reichen wir einen Antrag an ein beziehungsweise sagen wir den Leuten Bescheid oder sagen im... Ja, wir gehen in Form von einer Vorlage in die Verwaltung und gehen dann halt in Form von Beratungsfolgen durch die Verwaltung. Also im erster Schritt ist dann halt, dass da eventuell der Bauerschrift guckt, ist es notwendig, wie können wir das machen, da die Laterne hinzustellen oder die wieder zu reparieren, dann geht es in den Finanzausschuss. Da wird dann gesagt, haben wir auch Geld dafür und dann zum Schluss geben dann die Fraktionen noch ihren Senf dazu und ja, stimmen dort ab und das kann man auch nachvollziehen, dass es öffentliche Punkte sind, die dort behandelt werden.
Eine Frage mal, Robert, nur mal so für die Zukunft nochmal. Bei Heise zum Beispiel oder bei allen möglichen Diensten, die so Infos anbieten, bei Heise ist es am besten zu beobachten und www.heise.de kennen jetzt auch die meisten. Da gibt es ja immer diese kleinen Beiträge und darunter steht dann Kommentare und dann sind da die letzten drei Kommentare zu sehen, wo die Leute sich einfach dazu äußern, was sie zu dieser Sache denken. Gibt es Bestrebungen von kommunaler Seite aus, also von Seite der Regierung oder auch von eurer Seite, zu sagen, man baut so ein Feature ein, dass die einfach einen Kommentar hinterlassen können zu einem bestimmten Punkt, der da aufgeführt worden ist, online, in so einem Protokoll?
Wir machen am ersten Schritt, also in einer unserer Releases kommt jetzt das Thema rein, Forum für Kommunalpolitiker, wo heißt Kommunalpolitiker, sich diskutieren können, aber das ist dann auch wie gesagt ein geschlossener Bereich. Es sind halt nur viele Kommunalpolitiker, die da im Internet eine Plattform für ihre Diskussion haben und halt auch Vorlagen oder verschiedene Inhalte dann verweisen können. Zum Kontext Intensives Forum, aber wie gesagt nur für die Benutzergruppe Kommunalpolitiker.
Also nur lesend, die oder schreibend?
Also nur Kommunalpolitiker lesend und schreibend, aber Bürger halt noch gar nicht.
Schade eigentlich.
Also die Verwaltung ist natürlich auch bestrebt. Und auch positiv einerseits, dass es so ist, die Inhalte sehr genau zu kontrollieren, die da nach außen gehen. Und dort Akzeptanz zu schaffen, nicht nur beim Bürger, sondern auch innerhalb der Verwaltung. Ich meine, das sind ja auch immer Strukturen, die da schon ähnlichkeitenlos sind. Also von der Organisation halt. Muss ja auch einiges bei einer Einführung von einer IT-Lösung bedacht werden. Da müssen Prozesse anders gestaltet werden. Dann haben natürlich auch einige Verwaltungsmitarbeiter Angst, dass ihre Stelle wegfällt durch Autorierungen. Das klingt immer so leicht. Einspannen von irgendwelchen Stellen. Ich meine, da sitzen ja auch irgendwie reale Leute. Und viele Kommunen dürfen ja gar keine Leute mehr nachbesetzen. Das heißt, die haben halt ihre Schicht. Und über die Jahre scheiden halt Leute aus. Und die Stellen werden einfach nicht nachbesetzen. Und durch die Informationstechnik wird das aufgefangen. Aber ich sag mal, in der Verwaltung, da ist eigentlich eine größere Schwierigkeit auch da, solche Lösungen einzuführen. Weil auch dort Akzeptanz zu schaffen ist, wenn man solche Lösungen einführt.
Aber ich finde es ja...
Wir müssen auch gerne damit arbeiten. Auch die Kommunalpolitiker müssen es annehmen. Manche haben davon noch nicht mal eine E-Mail-Adresse. Und denen kommt man dann mit ins Internetzeug.
Aber ich finde es ja immerhin schon mal sehr fortschrittlich, dass auch Sachbearbeiter und Kommunalpolitiker da an diese Sachen reinschauen. Also ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie auch schon ein Problem der Verwaltung, dass dann nicht die eine Hand nicht weiß, was die andere macht. Und wenn da schon mal irgendwie ein Austausch ist, dass die Sachbearbeiter wenigstens gerade mal wissen, was irgendwie beschlossen wurde, dann finde ich das schon mal einen ganz erheblichen Fortschritt, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Also, was an internen Sachen angeht oder so. Weil ich denke mal, dass einfach dieses Nachrichtenwesen oder diese Informationsfluss in den Behörden auch auf jeden Fall noch verbessert werden muss. Und das ist ja auf Papier, aber manchmal auch gar nicht möglich.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist ja auch ein Thema im Rahmen der Electronic-Government-Thematik, DMF, Dokumentenmanagementsysteme. Da wird ja auch einiges gemacht. Also es sind eine Vielzahl von Projekten einfach in den Kommunen am Laufen, zumindest in den größeren. Es hat natürlich auch mit ein bisschen Geld zu tun, eine Lösung sich leisten zu können. Und in einigen Kommunen gibt es speziell Electronic-Government-Beauftragte, die sich darum kümmern, zu prüfen, welche Lösungen sinnvoll sind und diese dann bei der Einführung zu begleiten. Ich glaube, wir haben das schon eine ganz Menge gemacht. Das ist noch nicht genug, aber Step by Step, also wie gesagt, das Thema digitale Dignatur, kam aus der Sprache in der Sendung. Es gab im Vorhinein schon Projekte, wie so ein Bürgerinformationssystem von er geht das. Das ist meiner Meinung nach nur in Wiesbaden und irgendwo anders noch so als Pilot bereitgestellt worden. Es hat dadurch gescheitert, dass die Sicherheitsfaktor die Person am anderen Ende der Leitung zu identifizieren, sicher zu identifizieren, den Dokumenten und Daten, die dort ausgetauscht werden, eine Gründigkeit zu geben. Das ist zurzeit noch schwierig. Da warten viele Hersteller, dass es da einen vernünftigen Standard gibt, der dann auch von den meisten Anbietern und natürlich auch von kommunaler Seite gestützt wird.
Ja, Singanturen, sollten wir vielleicht einfach jetzt mal zu kommen?
Können wir ja machen. Das waren sehr, sehr viele Einblicke wiederum. Robert, es ist eigentlich interessant, weil heute so viele verschiedene Betroffene aus den verschiedenen Bereichen anrufen. Das ist fast wie bestellt. Insofern danken wir dir sehr.
Ich würde ganz gerne zwei Punkte noch abarbeiten.
Ja, mach das, mach das.
Ich muss sagen, dieser Open Source in den öffentlichen Behörden, das ist so, dass es gefördert wird. Und das ist auch richtig so. Dennoch ist es natürlich nicht so einfach, die Lösung umzustellen. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele Fachversuche, die einfach für die Dokumenten-Generierung, für Automation einfach so etwas nutzen. Und wenn man jetzt auf Open Office oder etwas anderes umstellen möchte, wobei ich diese Lösung, wenn man im Star-Office, also Open Office, halte ich noch nicht getraublich, weil einfach die Automation noch nicht das, also den Komfort von der Programmierung her bietet, wie es Word derzeit tut, dann muss natürlich auch die Umstellung bei den ganzen Fachversuchen bezahlt werden. Und davor, also wir sollen diese Summe bezahlen, die Verwaltung, das ist ein Punkt, der einen hohen Kostenfaktor hat. Deswegen kann man einfach auch Microsoft, also Word und Windows, nicht von den Arbeitsstationen verbannen. Das Bundeskarteilamt stand in der letzten Linux-Enterprise, die im Server umgestellt auf Samba und halt im Linux-Server. Im Bereich der Server wird sich eine Menge tun, das einige auf Linux umstellen. Aber ich glaube, in einem Arbeitsstationsbereich, da ist halt das Office-Paket da und da ist Windows da und da sind die ganzen Fachverfahren, die auf Windows aufsetzen. Und ich glaube, das wird so auch noch eine lange Zeit sein.
Die Frage, die sich mir da aufdrängt, ist nur, je später ich diesen Umstieg plane oder wage, desto teurer wird es doch denn. Bis dato haben wir zwar schon große Teile der Verwaltung zumindest unterstützend mit IT-Technik ausgestattet, aber es ist so, dass sehr viele Prozesse immer noch analog ablaufen. Und je mehr ich nicht auf das verlasse und je mehr meine Betriebsgeschichte sozusagen in Dokumenten in einem proprietären Format steckt, desto schwieriger wird es später zu machen. Und hier stellt sich mir eher die Frage, ob nicht die EU als Aufgabe hätte, verbindliche Dokumentenaustauschformate zu definieren, mit der sie ihre Bürgerinteressen...
Da wird ja auch was gemacht. Also erst mal muss ich sagen, dass verschiedene Initiativen im Rahmen der Standardisierung vom XML-Protokoll, vom XML-Standard, da gibt es so Unterarten für verschiedene Bereiche, für das Finanzwesen und natürlich auch für die Elektronik-Government. Und da wird versucht, verschiedene Formate, einfach XML-Formate zu schaffen und die dann auch durchzusetzen. Das dauert halt bloß noch ein bisschen. Und dann muss ich einfach sagen, ich bin jetzt niemand, der dieses Linux-Lager favorisiert und niemand, der dieses Microsoft-Lager favorisiert. Ich halte es eigentlich für die beste Lösung, wenn man diese beiden Lösungen kombiniert und guckt, was webmäßig ist. Und man muss auch sehen, dass viele Kommunen, wenn man denen eine Linux-Kiste hinstellt, die sind völlig überfordert. Also da ist ein Systemverwalter, der nebenbei noch Hauptlambsleiter ist oder so, der die EDV nebenbei macht, der ist mittlerweile noch überfordert, aus meiner Sicht. Und der hat halt einen NT-Hobel. Okay, es gibt bessere Sachen und er hat seine Schwächen, aber prinzipiell tut er das, was er soll.
Aber ich sehe das Problem, dass viele Verwaltungen ihre EDV-Vorgänge an den Produkten, an einer Firma, an den eingesetzten Produkten orientieren. Das heißt also, die Wege, die Datenwege, die Verwaltungsvorgänge, wie sie elektronisch ablaufen, sind orientiert daran, wie diese Software funktioniert. Das heißt also, wie diese Software-Schnittstellen sind, welche Programme verfügbar sind. Und sie sind nicht daran orientiert, wie es idealerweise sein sollte. Und dann wird geguckt, wie muss die Software sein, die ich da einsetzen kann. Und dann wird geguckt, okay, es gibt halt irgendwie Word und Excel. Das heißt, deswegen muss ich jetzt irgendwie Excel-Tabellen durch die Gegend schicken, nur weil es halt irgendwie das einzige Format ist, das mir angeboten wird.
Es gibt ja mit Office 2000, mit Office XP noch besser Ausbaustormate. Ich kann eine Word-Datei als HTML-Speichel, also die haben ja in unserer Verhandlung auch Word, also Word-Dokumente, Docs und FES-Dateien als Textbausteine. Und die werden halt über einen Konvertierungsdienst umgestellt. Also die werden ins HTML-Format konvertiert. Und ja, das ist aus meiner Sicht eine gute Lösung. Und Office XP bietet halt schon die Möglichkeit, das HTML-Daten abzulegen. Ja, das Top-Format irgendwie als Quali-Standard durchzusetzen. Das ist auch logisch aus Ihrer Sicht, aus der Microsoft-Wicht. Aber ich sag mal, gewisse Outdoor-Formate müssen sie halt irgendwie mittlerweile auch jetzt wunderbar unterstützen. Und XML und HTML ist dabei und das sind Standards. Und ich glaube, damit sieht das ganz gut aus.
Aber da du ja jetzt tatsächlich schon ein paar Aufträge im Rahmen deiner Firma da auch erlebt zu haben scheinen, das Problem, das ich kenne von Regierungsangelegenheiten, die dann irgendwie an der Firma gegeben werden, dass es immer so läuft, wir haben kein Geld, wir haben kein Geld, wir haben kein Geld, wir haben kein Geld, ho, wir haben 100.000 Mark, die müssen wir jetzt sofort umsetzen und dann muss jetzt die Lösung her und dann gucken die sich meistens nicht mal groß um, sondern innerhalb von fünf Tagen muss es dann das und das sein. Dann habt ihr diese Erfahrung auch gemacht.
Na ja, das ist jetzt ziemlich potentiert für das Problem. Ja, öffentliche Banken, da geht das noch von der Finanzierung her, aber es gibt echt viele Kommunen, die sind einfach pleite. Die sind einfach total pleite und die haben dieses Jahr irgendwie Gewerbeschwerausfälle ohne Ende. Und die sind halt auch verpflichtet, so ein bisschen so eine Lösung einzuführen und sich mit der Thematik zu befassen. Und die gucken wir natürlich auch fast im Rahmen unseres Geldbeutels. Ich meine, wir haben, wir vertreiben eine Standardlösung. Also es gibt ja die Standardlösung, es gibt Projektlösung. Das schönste ist natürlich die Projektlösung, wo ich genau für meine Kommune, für meine Vorgänge mir die ideale Anwendung erstellen lasse. Aber in der Praxis ist es einfach so, dass es sich keiner leisten kann. Das kann einfach niemand bezahlen. Das ist eine sehr gute Lösung. Das fängt einfach mit dem Geldbeutel zusammen. Und ja, das ist es eben.
Das liebe Geld. Robert, du hast noch einen Punkt auf deine Liste, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche, den du von dir aus noch abgehakt haben wolltest. Ist das richtig?
Ja, ich muss nochmal sagen, mit dem Schnittstellen. Also Künstlergeld hat uns ja schon so ein bisschen, ja, angesprochen. Also die Hersteller sind natürlich bedacht, die Verfahren auch ein bisschen pubertär zu halten. Das ist einfach so auf einer gewissen Angst herauf, dass jemand anders so die Daten einfach migrieren könnte und auf das Mitgliederprodukt umzustellen. Ich glaube, das ist auch nachvollziehbar.
Deswegen auch so ein bisschen Angst vor Open Source in dem Bereich?
Na ja, Open Source nicht direkt. Ich sag mal, wenn ein Kunde zu uns kommt und sagt, wir brauchen da folgende Daten aus ihrem Programm und in dem Format, dann ist man sicherlich im Rahmen von einer Aufwandsverbütung, machen wir das. Aber jeder Hersteller versucht natürlich auch, seine Ideen zu schützen. Wie weit das möglich ist, ist eine Sache für sich. Aber Schnittstellen gibt es da. Ich glaube nicht, dass es einen Hersteller gibt, der sich weiert, irgendwelche Daten nach außen zu geben. Ich glaube, wenn man sagt, hör mal zu, wir haben das Verfahren, wir möchten da eine Schnittstelle haben, und dann unterhalten sich die Hersteller von den Verfahren. Und der Aufwand für diese Schnittstelle wird halt von der Kommune vergütet. Oder wenn es im Interesse des Herstellers ist, dann sagt er vielleicht auch, ich komme euch entgegen und beteilige es das irgendwie so. Also ich sehe das nicht so schwarz. Also ich glaube, wie gesagt, wir haben mit dem Alex-Marie-Karabinem einen guten Stand in Deutschland. Und ich glaube, da muss man eine ganze Menge tun. Aber so schwarz ist er.
Gut, aber gerade für mich als Bürger will ich natürlich auch die Sicherheit haben, dass ich weiß, was da an Daten ausgetauscht wird und in welchem Format, ob diese Datenübertragungen sicher sind, ob das alles zur Seite in Ordnung kann. Oder wäre es natürlich schon schön, wenn es irgendwie öffentlich einsehbar wäre.
Das ist aber auch irgendwie ein Scheingefächt, jeder weiß, dass Sicherheit... Also ich kann eine Mauer bauen, aber es wird sicherlich Leute geben, die irgendwie drüber springen können. Das liegt ja gerade in der EDV und auch in anderen Bereichen des Lebens keine absolute Sicherheit. Man kann versuchen, eine maximale Sicherheit zu erreichen. Und das versuchen die Kommunen auch. Zum Beispiel die Hersteller, wenn wir halt z.B. Fremdprodukte ablösen, dann kriegt man ja eine Daten-CD, oder dann werden die Daten reingestellt, das ist ein Fremdverfahren, man versucht sie dann in sein eigenes Verfahren zu integrieren. Da gibt es sowas wie Datenschutzerklärung. Das heißt, ich versichere als Hersteller der Kommune, dass die Daten, die ich erhalten habe, nur fit in meinem Haus.
Ja, das ist ja richtig, nur das geht ja um die Systemsicherheit. Und das Argument ist ja im Prinzip von Microsoft. Unsere Software ist sicher, machen Sie sich mal keine Sorgen.
Ich habe mittlerweile auch eine Art Aversion entwickelt gegen die Leute, die immer in diese Microsoft-Richtung schießen. Ich höre wie gesagt nicht so...
Na gut, eure Firma dann möglicherweise auch so?
Microsoft, gut, bitte?
Eure Firma dann möglicherweise auch, oder? Oder gibt ihr denn die Protokolle irgendwie offen raus, die ihr verwendet, oder die Sachen, die jetzt...
Wir benutzen als Standardprotokolle, das ist HTTP, normal bei öffentlichen Inhalten. Und sobald es halt kritische Inhalte sind, die wir präsentieren im Internet, wird halt HTTPS dazu genommen. Und der Server-Abgleich, der geschieht, ist verschlüsselt und wie gesagt, wir bieten die Möglichkeit, dass nur öffentliche Daten überhaupt ins Internet gestellt werden. Also physisch, die sind auf der Web-Server-Linie nur Dokumente, die öffentlich eingesehnt werden können.
Robert, ich denke mal, jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich auch für die meisten, die jetzt nicht in so einer Firma arbeiten, ein bisschen zu kompliziert. Also brauchen wir dann über die Ecke eigentlich auch noch zu springen. Aber es ist okay dann auch zu wissen, dass ihr euch auch ein paar Standards wünscht, die dann im Endeffekt zu einer leichteren Umsetzung führen könnten. Und das waren wirklich ein paar coole Einblicke. Dank dir für den Anruf. Tschüss nach Hamburg. So, jetzt haben wir uns natürlich wieder festgequatscht, bis zum Get-Know wollten eigentlich ja noch mal auf einen anderen Aspekt des Themas eingehen. Vielleicht können wir den kurz noch anreißen, bevor wir ein bisschen Musik spielen und dann die Nachrichten machen.
Ich würde vielleicht eher noch auf das Signaturgesetz kurz eingehen wollen. Der Begriff ist jetzt ein paar Mal gekommen, elektronische Signaturen. Es gibt dafür also ein Gesetz, wo geregelt ist, wie dieser ganze organisatorische Rahmen ablaufen soll. Das heißt, so eine Signatur ist ein kleines, ein paar Zahlen, so vereinfacht gesagt, die ich zugeteilt kriege, die mit einem Passwort, mit meinem Passwort geschützt sind. Und mit Hilfe von mathematischen Verfahren kann ich mit dieser Zahlenreihe Dokumente praktisch digital unterschreiben. Das heißt, wir werden eine mathematische Verknüpfung, eine mathematische Berechnung gemacht. Und hinterher kommt eine Zahl raus, die man gegenüber überprüfen kann mit einem Teil des Schlüssels, den er zurückbehalten hat, meiner Signatur, die er zurückbehalten hat. Dann kann er dann sehen, ob das Dokument wirklich von mir unterschrieben worden ist.
Das wird schon wieder ausgestiegen.
Ich weiß zwar, wie es funktioniert, aber das war jetzt zweimal um die eigene Ecke gedreht.
Ja, es ist auch. Also es gibt halt zwei verschiedene paar Schlüsse und die einen bleiben bei dem, der die Signatur ausgibt, bzw. macht sie dann öffentlich, damit andere Dritte dann überprüfen können, ob die Signatur wirklich von dem angebracht wurde, der behauptet sie an.
Also ich habe einen Stein zerbrochen und die eine Hälfte des Steins gebe ich an die Öffentlichkeit und meinen Steinteil behalte ich und dann gucken die hinterher, wenn ich das so hergebe, dann gucken die, ob es passt sozusagen und setzen den Stein wieder zusammen.
Ja, das ist ein guter Vergleich.
Herrlich, naja, das ist doch wieder mal Spaß.
Aber stell dir nicht vor, wie ein Stein, sondern wie ein Teller, den du in die Luft wirfst und in 20.000 kleinen Stückchen. Wer schafft ihn wieder korrekt zusammenzusetzen, wer das Wissen dazu hat, der besitzt die Signatur.
Genau. Und gesetzlich geregelt ist das alles ein Signaturgesetz und da steht dann auch drinnen, dass es nur bestimmte Zertifizierungsanstalten gibt oder Zertifizierungsinstanzen, die sowas machen dürfen, die dann über die bestimmten technischen Voraussetzungen verfügen. Das heißt, sie schuldes Personal haben, die sichere Systeme haben und sowas. Und natürlich hat man sich auch überlegt, wie denn beim Kunden quasi oder bei den Leuten draußen, beim Bürger sowas aussehen soll. Und das ist bisher eigentlich auch noch der große Schwachpunkt, weil da hab ich in der Regel so eine Chipkarte krieg ich dann da. Die muss ich in so ein Lesegerät reinstecken, was an meinem PC dran hängt. Und es ist den meisten Leuten schon wieder viel zu viel Aufwand. Und da sind eben dann Computer dran beteiligt. Und da kann ganz viel schief gehen. Und da ist irgendwie Windows. Und dann gibt's Viren und trilianische Pferde und so eine Sachen. Ganze Sicherheit dann irgendwie ziemlich schnell wieder zu Dichte machen können, die das System an sich bietet. Also das System, was für die elektronischen Signaturen geplant ist, das haben Leute wirklich mal nachgedacht. Und es ist auch, was jetzt so die Sicherheit der mathematischen Sachen, die da vor sich gehen, angeht, ist es erst mal für ein paar Jahre sicher.
Es ist natürlich die Frage, ob ihr sowas traut und ob ihr überhaupt schon mal mit diesem Thema Kontakt gehabt habt. Also vielleicht habt ihr mal eine Mail bekommen, wo eine Signatur, was soll denn das denn, was ist denn das für eine Signatur? Na ja, die Mail ist von Peter, weiß ich ja auch oder so. Oder ob ihr vielleicht selber schon regelmäßig diese Signaturen verschickt und damit arbeitet und euch langsam an so eine Sache gewöhnt, obwohl es ein tierischer Aufwand ist. Also in meinem Fall zum Beispiel habe ich mich mal mit Online-Banken beschäftigt in dem Maße, dass ich mir so eine Karte besorgt habe. Das nennt sich glaube ich HBCI oder so. Da gab es oft so eine Karte dazu. Mein lieber Scholli, was Sie für ein Bohall gemacht haben. Ich hätte es nicht glauben können. Die haben mir drei Briefe geschickt. Da musste ich mit den Briefen nochmal zur Bank. Da musste ich nur eine Nummer abschreiben, die ellenlang war und ähnliches. Also es war wirklich nicht userfreundlich.
Das ist richtig. Wobei das bisherige TAN-Verfahren beim Online-Banking entspricht ja auch schon ein bisschen zu einer Signatur. Man unterschreibt ja auch elektronisch diesen Überweisungsvorgang, den du gemacht hast. Und das kommt dieser ganzen Sache schon recht nahe ran. Ein Problem dabei ist, was wir generell bei diesen elektronischen Vorgängen haben, ist, dass der Beweis last. Das ist eigentlich an sich noch ein riesen Themenbereich. Aber verkürzt gesagt, das Signaturgesetz sagt, dass dieses ganze System der elektronischen Unterschriften per Definition sicher ist. Das heißt, wenn irgendwie ein Missbrauch damit passiert, bin ich als Geschädigter, als Bürger in der Beweislast, in der Beweisnot, dann nachweisen zu müssen, dass ich irgendwas nicht unterschrieben habe. Und das ist genau der Knackpunkt, den wir auch als CCC so ein bisschen als schwierig ansehen. Solange Bürger diese ganze Technik nicht durchschauen können, kann da einfach noch relativ viel schiefgehen. Und ich hab dann auch natürlich keine Möglichkeit mehr nachzuweisen, dass so ein System sicher ist. Das ist genau wie jetzt Problematik bei der EC-Card mit Banken, also Geschichte der EC-Karte geklaut. Pin hab ich natürlich nicht draufgeschrieben, sondern irgendwie nur im Kopf gemerkt. Trotzdem ist das Konto leer geräumt und ich muss dann der Bank erklären, wie das passieren konnte. Kann ich natürlich nicht, weil nur die wissen, wie das funktioniert. Ich steh da halt blöd da. Und genau das gleiche Problem gäbe es dann auch bei der Signaturkarte, wenn da irgendwie ein Missbrauch mit passiert.
Wenn ihr euch zum Thema äußern möchtet, rund um das, was wir jetzt angesprochen haben, mit der dignitalen Signatur oder zum Thema E-Government, was das große Thema des Chaosradios heute Abend ist, generell 0-3-1-70-97-1-1-0 ist die Telefonnummer. Frank hat ja gerade noch mal einen kurzen Abriss gemacht. Andreas ist mal im Studio und meine Person Max. Wir machen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen Nachrichten und ihr könnt euch überlegen, was ihr möglicherweise zum Thema beitragen möchtet.
Wenn Fritz in der Triebnis, dann 103, 1.
Niveau 29. Tagsauf wieder schönes Wetter. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 17 bis 20 Grad morgen. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Bundesaußenminister Fischer hat die Einigung über die neue palästinensische Regierung begrüßt. Er sagte, das palästinensische Volk könne nun eine wichtige Etappe im Reformprozess erreichen. Auch die EU in Brüssel erklärte, die Einigung werde den Weg für die Wiederaufnahme von Friedensbesprechen ebnen. In Berlin-Neukölln hat es eine tödliche Schießerei gegeben. Dabei wurde ein Polizist getötet, ein weiterer wurde schwer verletzt. Die Polizisten wollten in einer Wohnung einen Mann verhaften, gegen den wegen einer Messersticherei ein Haftbefehl vorliegt. Die Rürup-Kommission wird möglicherweise bereits heute erste Reformvorschläge für die Rente vorlegen. Darum hatte Sozialministerin Schmidt gebeten, damit der SPD-Sonderparteitag am 1. Juni sie noch beraten kann. Im Gespräch sind Einschnitte bei den Rentenzuwächsen und längere Lebensarbeitszeiten. Bei einem Unfall sind drei amerikanische Marineinfanteristen im Irak ums Leben gekommen. Sieben Männer wurden verletzt, damit sind seit Kriegsbeginn im Irak 131 US-Soldaten getötet worden. Die ersten ausländischen Mitarbeiter der Vereinten Nationen sind in den Irak zurückgekehrt. Sie sollen vor allem bei der Verteilung von Lebensmitteln und Wasser und bei der Minenräumung helfen. Für Verkehrsservice hat keine Meldungen weiter. Gute Fahrt.
Sie ist unterwegs, sie macht Spaß und ganz bestimmt irgendwann kommt sie auch zu dir.
Die Fritz Disco am Freitag ab 22 Uhr in der Diskothek Kurgarten in Prenzlau mit den Fritz-DJs Anja und René.
Ja.
So, jetzt sind alle noch mal wach geworden. Das war auch beabsichtigt im Chaosradio auf Fritz am heutigen Abend. 0 Uhr 34, das heißt die Sendung neigt sich langsam dem Ende zu. Wir haben noch ein halbes Stündchen Zeit zu sprechen. Thema heute Abend die E-Regierung. Das heißt nicht, das hat nichts mit Erektion zu tun, sondern das...
Das hat nichts mit E's.
Auch nicht mit E werfen und ähnlichem. Man kann vielleicht die Regierung auf eine gewisse Art und Weise anwerfen, aber nichts anderes. Es geht um E-Government, das heißt Beteiligung an unserer wunderbaren Politik auf elektronischem Wege. Das hat zwei Richtungen. Das heißt, es kann sowohl die Beteiligung sein, dass die Politiker uns an ihrer Arbeit teilhaben lassen. Der gläserne Politiker sozusagen. Was macht er eigentlich? Worüber haben die gesprochen? Welche Entscheidungsfindungsprozesse gab es da? Wofür geben die eigentlich unsere Kohle aus? Und andersrum aber auch, das was man aus jedem besseren Spieleforum zum Beispiel kennt. Ich schreibe der Firma, pass mal auf Kollegen, mein Grafiktreiber funktioniert so nüchste und ich würde gerne, dass ihr euch darum kümmert. Das sollte mit der Regierung doch eigentlich auch möglich sein. Und es gibt noch ganz viele kleine Ausformungen des Ganzen. Und da haben wir heute Abend auch schon ein paar angesprochen. Wollten jetzt glaube ich nochmal eine ganz spezielle Richtung gehen, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Im Studio sind meine Personen Max, Andreas und Frank, der jetzt einfach mal die Überleitung wagt.
Genau, wir haben, also es war ein bisschen die Rede von Dokumentenmanagement-System. Das heißt also, wenn die Verwaltungen jetzt nicht mehr mit Papierakten durch die Gegend laufen, sondern es einfach alles in irgendeine Datenbank werfen oder auf so einen Dokumenten-Server werfen, dann haben wir das Problem, dass da Sachen zusammenkommen, die vielleicht so nicht zusammenkommen sollten. Das heißt also Personendaten, wenn zum Beispiel innerhalb von Behörden es ist vielleicht noch relativ harmlos, aber wenn es dann geht, wenn ein Finanzamt beteiligt ist und irgendwie das Sozialamt oder vielleicht möglicherweise auch noch Krankenkassen und der Bürger keinen Überblick mehr hat, welche Daten wo landen. Und da geraten wir in eine ganz gefährliche Sache, wenn die Sachen dann plötzlich von Leuten abrufbar sein sollen in der Verwaltung, die da aber eigentlich gar nicht hin sollten, nach ihrer Definition. Bisher ist es so klar, ich kann nicht einfach in eine Behörde gehen und sagen, meine Akten, dann geht der nicht los. Dann geht es in eine andere Behörde und kann da Akten abrufen. Wenn es aber alles elektronisch ist, dann brauchen wir dafür sehr ausgefeilte Systeme der Berechtigung, wer welche Daten abrufen kann. Und da sehe ich auch noch eine Gefahr beim E-Government, dass der Bürger da möglicherweise das Vertrauen verliert. Wenn er sagt, um Gottes Willen, dann wird ja alles da nicht elektronisch gespeichert, alles ist abrufbar, wer kann die Daten einsehen, was passiert mit den Daten. Da sehe ich schon auch noch eine Gefahr der Ablehnung durch den Bürger, dass er da zu große Ängste hat. Und ich denke, die sind unter Umständen auch berechtigt. Also wenn ich mir so Sachen angucke, wie aktuell die nächste Volkszählung zum Beispiel soll durch einen Registerabgleich gemacht werden. Das heißt, es gehen nicht mehr so Leute rum mit irgendwie zetteln und sagen, schönen guten Tag, ich mache hier eine Zählung, wie viele Leute wohnen denn hier. Sondern es passiert alles automatisch. Wir werden automatisch alle gezählt, indem die Einwohner-Melderegister abgeglichen werden mit den Daten der Wohnungsinhaber, wie viele Wohnungen werden also Haushalte generiert. Und das ist irgendwie eine ganz spannende Sache, was da vor sich geht. Es ist natürlich klar, die Regierung hat auch aus der letzten Volkszählung gelernt. Das war ja nicht so der Bringer, da gab es dann auch ziemlich unschöne Szenen. Und das sollte man sich eigentlich nochmal ersparen. Dann haben wir gesagt, okay, wir haben die sowieso alle im Computer, warum, sondern wir müssen nicht einfach mal irgendwie einen Computer durchzählen. Das ist nicht so einfach als das.
Ja, wir werden mittlerweile immer gerne überlieber umgangen, weil wir eigentlich der Faktor sind, der es am schwierigsten macht.
Aber eigentlich geht es ja nur um den Menschen, nicht?
Na egal, 077 97 1 1 0 0, die Nummer für den Blue Moon heute Abend fürs Chaosradio. Und am Telefon ist hoffentlich noch der Andreas. Hallo Andreas. Sorry, dass wir dich so lange haben warten lassen, aber die Diskussion erfordert ein gewisses Maß an Tiefe. Und die muss man auch haben an der Stelle. Was möchtest du zum Thema sagen?
Ja, ich arbeite in der Service-Stelle Jugendbeteiligung. Und das ist ein Projekt, wo wir bundesweit Jugendbeteiligungsprojekte unterstützen. Zum Beispiel so ein Projekt, wie das, was heute schon wo heute schon so erzählt worden ist, das Jugendforum. Aber halt bundesweit und ganz vielfältige Projekte. Und da versuchen wir auch viel übers Internet zu machen. Und wir sehen eher also das Problem, dass, obwohl das Internet ein Netz ist, ist gerade da halt mit der Vernetzung oft nicht so glatt, weil es ganz viele Informationen gibt, aber man weiß nicht, wo kriegt man die her genau. Und auf jeder Seite stehen andere Informationen. Es gibt nicht, wo alles gebündelt steht. Und da sind wir ja dabei, so verschiedene Tools zu entwickeln. Wir haben Datenbanksysteme wie zum Beispiel gemeinsame Datenpoole, die aber auf ganz allen Seiten, ganz verschiedenen Seiten integriert sind, wo Informationen eingespeist werden auf einer Seite, aber in einem zentralen Datenpool, zum Beispiel Veranstaltungsdatenbank. Und ja, also diese Datenbank von ganz verschiedenen Seiten gefüttert wird. Und wenn ich halt auf meiner Seite was eingebe, das dann auch auf anderen Seiten geht.
Da kann ich natürlich als kritischer Leser dann genauso gut fragen, woher soll ich denn wissen, ob eure Daten die sind, den ich trauen kann. Weil alles was ich im Netz lese, von dem weiß ich, das kann so genau so gut 100% Bullshit sein, wie es 100% trustworthy ist.
Ja, aber das kann man natürlich nicht vermeiden. Ich meine, wenn mehr Leute da was einspeisen, ist natürlich auch die Gefahr groß, dass dann auch mal was dabei ist, was nicht der Wahrheit entspricht. Aber das lässt sich auch nicht verändern, wenn es nur einer macht.
Darf ich da eine kurze Frage? Und zwar, wer ist denn die Servicestelle Jugendbeteiligung? Ist das ja eine Regierungsorganisation, ein NGO, oder auf welchen rechtlichen Füßen versucht ihr da Beteiligung zu erwirken?
Na, wir sind nicht direkt eine Regierungsorganisation, wir sind ein Projekt, das Jugendliche mal konzeptioniert haben, weil sie gemerkt haben, wir überall in Deutschland arbeiten, Jugendliche in Projekten. Und es sind halt wirklich tausende Projekte, die es in Deutschland gibt. Aber es gibt nirgendwo die Informationen zusammenfließen und nirgendwo generell mal Jugendprojekte unterstützt werden. Und damit sind wir zur damaligen Jugendministerin gegangen. Und jetzt gibt es halt diese ständigen Beteiligungen, die auch von der Bundesjungenministerin unterstützt wird, aber in Regerschaft von unabhängigen Stiftungen ist und wo auch Jugendliche arbeiten.
Ich sehe gerade, euch gibt es schon seit 2001, ne? Das ist natürlich auch schon eine lange Zeit. Es ist verwunderlich, dass man dann auch nichts von euch gehört hat, obwohl es euch jetzt schon drei Jahre gibt. Ist das das Problem grundsätzlich? Ich gehört noch mal, wie viel wir damit machen. Nein, ich will auch nicht sagen, dass es einen Sender repräsentieren. Aber es ist mir gerade nicht so geläufig gewesen und ich wundere mich heute auch positiv überrascht, wie viele Projekte es da eigentlich gibt. Aber das Ding ist, diese Namen sind aufgrund dieser Masse auch irgendwie Schall und Rauch. Das ist das Jugendforum, Jugendbeteiligung, Jugend hier, Jugend da. Du weißt eigentlich nie so genau, was ist jetzt eigentlich was. Deswegen ist es nett, wenn du noch mal kurz umreißen würdest, was ihr zum Beispiel beispielhaft für ein Projekt gemacht habt. Wo du sagen würdest, da gab es eine gute Beteiligung. Das war etwas, wo Jugendliche elektronisch eine Menge mitgemacht haben.
Also zum Beispiel gab es 2000, Jahr im Jahr 2000, war das eine deutsche Jugendkonferenz und daraus hat sich eine Internetseite entwickelt, die heißt www.u26.de, an der Jugendliche auch mitgearbeitet haben und wo elektronisch viel diskutiert worden ist. Und weil gerade auch das umgesetzt worden ist, dass es halt, da gibt es ganz viele Diskussionsfonds und die sind nicht nur auf der Seite eingebunden, sondern auch auf ganz vielen anderen Seiten. Und das kann halt jeder auch bei seiner Seite machen und da wird halt, wurde halt der Versuch, dass es halt nicht nur läuft, dass es 10 Diskussionsfonds zu einem Thema gibt und in jedem diskutieren zwei, sondern dass es halt auf ganz vielen verschiedenen Seiten das Gleiche gibt, dass Informationen sich auch wirklich verbreiten und nicht nur einer kleinen Menge von Leuten zugenießen. Und dann arbeiten wir halt jetzt gerade daran, die ganzen Jugendprojekte zu vernetzen und so zu vernetzen, dass sie selber auch Jugendliche unterstützen können. Also weil es halt wirklich tausende Jugendprojekte in Deutschland gibt und ganz viele Jugendliche, die schon sehr viele Erfahrungen gemacht haben. Und da unterstützen wir, die jetzt so regionale Service-Stellen aufzubauen, dass die bei sich zu Hause Ansprechpartner sind für andere Jugendliche. Und das soll natürlich auch ganz viel übers Internet gehen und da entwickeln. Wir haben hier zusammen Veranstaltungs-Karten, Banken und so weiter.
Andreas, kurze Frage nur, weil wenn ich jetzt jemand bin, der sich dafür interessiert, der sagt, ich hab hier ein Projekt oder ich hab was, wo ich nicht mehr so weiterkomme, dann kann man sich an euch auch wenden und sagen, ich möchte gerne Hilfe haben, was dieses Projekt anbelangt und ihr gebt dann eure Struktur, eure Erfahrung und helft demjenigen von euch aus oder macht ihr das nur, wenn ihr die Initiative ergreift?
Nein, nein, nein.
Andreas, vielen Dank. Wir werden am Ende der Sendung auch noch mal alle Internetadressen, die wir heute im Laufe der drei Stunden gesammelt haben, zum Besten geben. Sei nicht böse und fühl dich nicht auf die Füße, dass mir das jetzt nicht geläufig war. Wir haben mit euch schon mal was gemacht, das glaube ich auch. Aber wie gesagt, bei so vielen Sachen weiß man manchmal einfach nicht mehr, was es so gibt und deswegen ist es gerade gut, dass du dich noch mal gemeldet hast und das auch noch mal hier gesagt hast. Andreas, vielen Dank. Mach's gut. Die Beleitung war auch so ein bisschen rauschig. Wir entschuldigen uns dafür, war so ein bisschen leise aus dem Hintergrund, aber das ist halt manchmal so. Da ist mal die eine Telefonleitung so, die andere so. Wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit, so eine Stündchen noch, wenn ihr noch was sagen wollt. 033 77 91 1 0 für den schnellen Kommentar. Ansonsten haben wir noch den Martin aus Hellersdorf. Na, Martin?
Ja, guten Abend.
Das ist schon ein bisschen präsenter von der Stimme her.
Ja, also ich wollte sagen zu diesem E-Government, dass ich sowieso ein bisschen früher auswärts gelebt habe und seitdem habe ich ja Verbindungen ins Ausland. Ich weiß ganz genau, dass in Estland und Finnland diese E-Government schon, naja, wahres Leben ist, sag ich mal. Also die haben dort so einen Personalausweis seit einem oder zwei Jahren eingeführt. Da ist so ein Chip dabei und dann hat man PIN dabei. Und dann kann man im Internet Verträge abschließen und seine Steuererklärung machen und Anträge füllen und so alles. Und die PIN, also im Gegensatz zu den deutschen PINs, wenn man zum Beispiel bei der Bankkarte bekommt, die kann man dort auch bei Bankkarten immer ändern. Wenn man der Meinung ist, sag ich mal, ja, jemand hat mir über die Schulter gekickt, dann geht man zum nächsten Automaten und holt um die Ecke und ändert das einfach mal. Und sich nur neu merken kann.
Sind die genau so lang oder sind die sogar länger?
Man kann also vier bis sechs Stellen sind die dort, das ist normaler. Und diesen PIN für diese Personalscheiß, da kann man das 24 Stellen oder so machen. Man muss es sich nur merken können.
Hast du das selber dann auch ausprobieren können in dem Rahmen oder konntest du da immer nur zuschauen, weil du jetzt nur so als Gast sozusagen in dem Land warst?
Na, ich müsste dann dort wohnhaft sein, dann würde ich diesen auch bekommen können.
Hast du eine Ahnung, ob es da eine bestimmte Beschränkung gibt, also eine Obergrenze mit Sachen, die du dann da rechtsverbindlich abschließen darfst?
Eigentlich nicht. Da gibt es so einen Start-Server und da gibt es auch diese Daten, wie jetzt gesagt wurde, da gibt es so eine Start-Datei und das ist wirklich nur den anderen.
Du musstest ja auch so Gesichter gesehen. Wir ziehen hier wirklich gerade alles zusammen. Wenn wir es schon hören, so Start-Server und Start-Dateman.
Na ja, das ist nicht so wie hier mit diesen Meldestellen, die alle örtlich und welche Daten da lagern, sondern naja, die Staaten haben nur eben 1, 5 und 5 Millionen oder so.
Klar, die hatten auch kein drittes Reich gehabt.
Es geht jetzt so um die Begrifflichkeit, wenn ich das anstehe, ne?
Ne, das nicht. Also da ist immer irgendwie Demokratie oder Eierwelle gewesen.
Das Dezentrale Meldewesen ist halt ein Grund, warum wir das haben.
Ja, eben.
Und ich denke, das ist auch ganz gut so. Und gerade bei diesen Sachen wie elektronischen Signaturen, Bürgerkarten, digitalen Prints und sowas, finde ich immer sehr schwierig, da diese Hangzungen zentralisieren. So, das war gerade so das Eingriff.
Da ist so eine Personenziffer dabei auch. Also wenn es, sag ich mal, fünf harten Kauses gibt, also und die zufällig auch am selben Tage am selben Ort geboren sind, dann hat jeder doch sein eigenes Ziffer sozusagen.
Nur dann oder haben sie grundsätzlich eine nationale Personenziffer?
Grundsätzlich, also das war es.
Und was haben die so, wenn die das schon länger haben, wenn die auch schon ihre ersten Erfahrungen damit gesammelt haben, gab es da auch mal Klage von den Leuten oder besondere Atem des Missbrauchs?
Also es wurde irgendwie, die haben sich irgendwie auch solche Gedanken gemacht, da könnte was passieren und so, aber bis jetzt ist nichts Schlimmes bis jetzt noch passiert.
Was sagen die?
Ja also ich hab nichts gehört, sag ich mal so, ich verfolge das ja.
War das jetzt Estland, Lettland?
Lettland noch nicht. Hab ich auch geguckt, aber die haben das nicht.
Also wenn die das schaffen mit der Einwohnerzahl, dann könnte es in Berlin auch funktionieren, aber das glaube ich ja nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das wollen.
Vielleicht würde das später durch diese europäische Einigung, die ich auch sehr begrüße, dann europäisch geregelt werden oder so. Weil ich meine, wenn man hier, Deutschland ist ja auch relativ klein, oder sag ich mal hier die ganzen Länder, also wenn die ganze Kontinent, sag ich mal, EU, mit diesen neuen Mitgliedern auch zusammenwärts, wenn die alle sich einheitlich diese Kennzeichnung machen würden, dann würde es wirklich etwas bringen. Weil ich meine, ich bin ja ab und zu mal über die Grenze hier oder hier oder so. Und immer ein anderes System da zu haben, ich verstehe, wenn da die Kultur oder die Sprache an das ist, aber das ist zu kompliziert.
Ja, also irgendwie, ich habe jetzt die Erfahrung gemacht, ich war im Urlaub in Belgien vor einer Woche und alleine in Tatsache, dass das monetäre System wirklich umgestellt ist und wir uns alle schon so ein bisschen in den Euro gewöhnt haben und nicht mehr so der Markt nach trauern, man geht da einkaufen, als würde man in dem Land auch wohnen. Das ist ganz merkwürdig, die Leute sprechen schon eine andere Sprache, aber du hast das Gefühl, ja gut, die reden jetzt halt eine andere Art von Deutsch. Die reden halt belgisch, quatsch, die reden halt französisch in dem Fall.
Französischer oder holländischer, das ist ein bisschen teurer. Oder billiger, je nachdem.
Ja, nee, aber das ist sehr, sehr merkwürdig gewesen, weil man hat dann das Gefühl, man hat die gleiche Berechtigung da zu sein. Dieses Geld ist echt ein Identifikationsfaktor, der nicht zu unterschätzen ist.
Und zusammen wachsend wird.
Ja, hammer. Aber nur weil du jetzt mal da warst, ich weiß nicht, ob du das beurteilen können wirst, Martin. Fandest du das denn toll, hatten die irgendwie ein leichteres Leben dadurch? War das alles easier? Oder haben die sich genauso angekotzt, wenn die vor dem Server saßen und so jetzt wollen wir die Info auch noch haben?
Also sag ich mal so, die Länder sind schon ein bisschen länger, sag ich mal, bei diesem Internet-Teil da, mit der Bevölkerung kürzenteils schon befasst. Also die hatten so ein paar Jahrchen vorher als Deutschland, sag ich mal, diesen Internet-Boom oder so. Und ja, da wurde es auch vor ein paar Jahren erst eingeführt. Und dann war es eigentlich schon eine gewünnte Sache. Also die Rentner haben gesagt, naja, was wollen die jungen Leute erstmal von uns und so. Aber ja, das Stadtwesen ist da sehr zukunftsorientiert. Also nicht so wie hier und welche Leute setzen sich in Talkshows hin und reden über so ein Zeug, was für ein Gesetz sind, die geändert werden müsste, was sowieso schon von der Zeit, schon vor 20 Jahren, erstmal überholt worden ist. Zum Beispiel kotzt mich wirklich, wenn ich mal so sagen darf, das deutsche Lahn-Schlussgesetz an. Das ist in keinem anderen Land berufig gewesen. Und das ist wirklich schlimm.
Das wäre doch mal der Diskussionsstoff, aber wir haben leider keine Zeit mehr. Ich glaube, wir sind eigentlich richtig warm geworden jetzt erst im Chaosradio. Wir bräuchten jetzt noch mal sechs Stunden, dann hätten wir es. Dank dir für den Anruf, Martin. Macht gut und eine schöne Nacht. Vielen Dank, dass ihr alle angerufen habt aus Berlin und Brandenburg und zum Chaosradio, was beigetragen habt, hier auf Fritz. Wir wollten einfach noch mal kurz am Ende so ein bisschen zusammenfassen, was wir heute so thematisch hatten und haben damit ja auch ein paar Internetadressen zu verbinden, wenn ihr euch nochmal schlau machen möchtet und ein bisschen nachlesen möchtet, worum es heute ging. Andreas, hast du so einen zettelchen Jahr, ne?
So einen groben Überblick, ich denke mal zunächst ist natürlich Chaosradio CCC.de die Adresse ohne www.desabends. Wir versuchen und sind wie immer bemüht da auch noch ein paar Informationen reinzustellen. Mal gucken, wann wir das schaffen. Vielleicht gibt uns der morgige Abend Gelegenheit dazu. Des Weiteren hatten wir über Jugendforum gesprochen, da hatten wir aber keine konkreten URLs. Ich denke, die finden sich bei den anschlägigen Suchmaschinen unter dem Stichwort Jugendforum und zum Beispiel Köpenick. Wir hatten www.jugendbeteiligung.info vorhin von Andreas. Wir hatten politik-digital.de auf jeden Fall auch noch angesprochen. Wir hatten elektronische-demokratie.de. Ich hoffe, das heißt wirklich so. Das hat Markus vorhin erzählt. Und das denke ich war es weitestgehend.
www.bundesregierung.de lohnt sich tatsächlich auch. Es gab eine Zeit lang, da ist man da draufgesurft und hat immer nur so ein repräsentatives Bildchen gesehen. Und hier wurde der Bundeskanzler Klick. Mittlerweile werden sehr, sehr viele Texte und auch erklärende Texte unter www.bundesregierung.de geliefert und ins Netz gestellt. Das heißt, man fühlt sich da wirklich unterhalten, möchte man so sagen.
Ganz toll, kann ich übrigens empfehlen, ist HIP, heute im Bundestag, vom Bundestag. Kannst du als Newsletter abonnieren. Kommst da irgendwann ein bisschen unregelmäßig, aber irgendwie gefällt mir ziemlich gut. Also da gibt es halt so immer meistens so drei bis zehn Stichpunkte, Themen, bis zum meisten Antworten auf Anfragen und so eine Geschichte. Und das ist eigentlich immer eine ganz spannende Sache. Also dann weißt du einfach so, was sie da im Tagesgeschäft machen, was da so vor sich geht, welche Sachen aktuell sind. Und das ist eigentlich immer so ganz nett zu lesen. Das ist viel spannender als Zeitung.
Und für den Fall, dass das jetzt alles brodeln sollte und ihr jetzt erst so richtig warm geworden seid, ihr habt einen Kaffee getrunken, könnt nicht mehr einschlafen, das Thema geht euch im Kopf rum. Es gibt noch eine Gelegenheit, auch mit Chaosradio-Leuten über dieses Thema zu sprechen, und zwar am morgigen Abend.
Und zwar in der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin Mitte im Hinterhaus. Das ist der Chaos Computer Club Berlin und das sind Vereinsräume. Wir haben da eine monatliche Veranstaltungsreihe namens Datengarten. Und da wollen wir nochmal die Ergebnisse der heutigen Sendung zusammenfassen, damit euch darüber sprechen. Kommt vorbei, Eintritt ist frei, los geht's gegen 20 Uhr.
Wir werden uns jetzt hier verabschieden, zumindest akustischerweise. Es geht weiter mit Martin Petersdorf und dem Night Flight. Im Studio waren Andreas, Frank und meine Person Max. Wir freuen uns, dass ihr zugehört habt und hoffen, dass das auf die eine oder andere Warte ein bisschen inspirierend war. Und sagen Tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal. Chaosradio vermutlich, falls nichts dazwischenkommt, nächsten Monat wieder am letzten Mittwoch des Monats. Dann die 82.
Ausgabe.
Bis dann, tschüss.